Yes, sir. Cheers.
Cheers.
And we're live and we're live so much.
Talk about so much to talk about years.
It's been awhile. It's been awhile.
And uh,
one of the reasons why you're here,
it's because I was mostly of Jackson. I
mean, we should just get right into this.
You can't do it or should we
let them at the Budweiser?
I haven't even eat breakfast. I
didn't eat breakfast. I'm like,
I'm going to drink beer with you.
I already know he's getting me beer.
And that way it can hit me a lot faster
and I'll loosen up my lips a lot sooner.
We can do whatever you want. It's
up to you. You look in thick dude.
How much do you weigh now, man? So I've
been, um, so here's a crazy story I go to,
I go to, um, the Pi to, Cause
Dana tells me I can't go to 55.
So I go to talk to tell you,
you can't go. Why? Look at,
he says I'm getting old and
older and just say, he said old,
I'm getting old and card, right.
So I said, I'm going to go to the,
to the bi. You guys have this
amazing facility with the pis,
towns for a performance institute for
people on the UFC performances too.
And uh, they have trainers and
Dietitian nutrition, right?
So I'm going there to meet with them to
get a guideline and some kind of plan
that we can attack so I can go
down. I look, I met with your guys,
they said it's okay while on their second
day into all this like crazy testing
you do,
right.
They have all kinds of tests that
they run where you get on these bikes.
And I mean like, fuck, I was the
Olympic training center testing.
Um, uh, I wanted to say
Joe Silva walked in,
but then that's not right because he's
not there anymore. So, uh, Maynard, no,
Sean Shelby comes in and says, [inaudible]
my prayer really wants to fight you.
You want to take this fight? And I was at,
uh, well, I thought it was going to 55.
And he said, yeah, he called you out and
really wants to fight you. And I was like,
well, fuck. Okay. I'll finance. Sure.
Done. That's fine. But next door,
can I go to Vinny via, you know, like God
damn. So how does Perry thing I'll start.
It was, um, Felder's
opponent got hurt. Um,
I called the fight gay. She goes,
because Vic got hurt. So I was like,
I'll go to 55 by [inaudible].
Um, crazy shit just happened.
And then the parry fight, they offered
me and I called Perry, said, hey man,
I know we're trying together, but this is
10 days notice. Let's do this. He's like,
fuck him. That'd be great. Let's do
this. So that's how that started.
And then I didn't get the fight.
That was the end of it for me.
I wanted to use to go back to one to 55
and then all of a sudden he's calling me
out and fell the winds of fighting.
Perry,
you were going to fight barrier where
you were at least thinking about it?
I was like in the mix.
Right. But I couldn't,
I didn't get cleared
because I had stitches.
Could I just fought a what? I
don't know 10 days before. So, um,
plus I was in the hospital
having my new son,
so it was kind of a weird time for
everything, but I was wild, wild,
wild shit and out now and now I'm fighting
Perry. You November 10th, then Denver.
Well,
what was,
what was gonna happen was Jackson and
Winkeljohn we're supposed to be here
today, right? Well you had,
I mean you've been with
them for how long man?
I want to say
before my WC days.
So I went on the more than 10
years. Yeah, easily. Yeah, easily.
More than 10 years.
I,
I don't think there's another athlete
there that's been the longer besides Diego
Sanchez who's been there
since the beginning,
but he left for a little while for
the while came back. Um, so me,
you know Holly, but she was
with wink before he merged. So,
but like with actually Jackson Jackson
and I'm like, they're like the one,
you know, everyone else kind of
either left the jam or retired.
So what the fuck happened?
Like how did they decide that they were
going to corner my Perry? Who by the way,
I like a lot. And I have nothing against
to say pair either. I don't this, this,
this has nothing to do with it. With Perry
has a fun dude. I like that guy a lot.
No problem with him on the boat.
Took them shooting with me and when he
was down there part or part of the action,
you know a Frank Lester who's helping him
with his pads, friend of mine, you know,
so he comes out shooting with me.
We go out in the boat and have fun and um,
so this has nothing to do with them.
I just asked when I went to go to 55 and
then Perry called me out and wants to
fight. Sure, no problem. But I went
to talk to Greg and we can say, Hey,
this guy is brand new to the gym,
right? He's only been here one camp,
couple of months.
I said,
I don't think that it's okay for
him to come in and call me out.
Like that's not, not not
right. So if he is doing that,
I don't think we should allow him to,
to train here for this fight.
If fucking Winkeljohn
tells me, yeah, you know,
I thought you called him out and Oh,
this is a shit ass and lies like to
your face. So to me he was like, yeah,
sure, no problem. I'll clear it up
and we won't have any issues. Um,
and then the next day he calls me on
the phone and says, you know what?
I thought about it.
If we don't have periods and I don't
get paid and I need to get paid for this
fight, and uh, uh, cause you just pay
Greg, I don't make any money to the gym,
so we're just gonna go with him.
And then basically tells me I'm
no longer welcome in the gym.
And he said the team had a meeting,
bullshit. The team didn't have a meeting.
I talked to everybody that there
was no meeting, there's no habit.
So to me it's like the loyalty of
week taking over this gym is just,
it's just shit, man. It turned
into like a puppy mill. It's all,
it's all about money now and not the old
Jackson. When, when I used to work out,
we're just getting into this I guess.
Huh? Alright. Start chugging, search,
hug and shit.
Back when I first moved down
here and I went to Greg's,
when the tap out guys picked me up
and introduced me and all that. Right.
But when you're on the tap
out show, I remember, Oh yeah.
That a reality show that will
mask called Greg and gotten me.
That's how I got involved
with them. Right. I,
I left Linda Garcia was fighting
Roger Ward two were my best friends,
Roger would call it. That was by damn
right. Mother fucking Mexican. God Damn,
I forgot about that fight.
Go to fight pass to bring that up.
Um, are still wild is due
to other men. So do I man.
And um, so he calls me like, come on,
I need you to come down for a week.
Come for one week.
Helped me get ready for Roger.
He took the fight on my three
weeks notice something outlandish.
You just like me and Leonard
Do. Right. So I go down there.
I literally never left.
When I went down,
first day I walked in
the Jacksons in Rashad,
Keith Saint-pierre, Joe
Daddy's Stevenson. Uh,
I mean the list goes on and on
and on. And I was like, wow,
this is what a real gym is like. This
is what, and they all accepted me.
It was like a duck. I was like
in the family, right? I call,
I owned a house in Denver. I called my
grandma. I said, I'm never coming home.
I'm staying here, sell the house.
Right. And I literally never went home.
She would just slowly come down to visit
me and bring me truckloads of shit.
Right? Literally, I
lived in a closet, man,
fuck it. A third as big as this room,
we had a bunk bed, me and Leonard and a,
if one person who was standing up,
the other person had to be in the bed.
That's how small this room was. Wow.
And I lived there for two years above,
above Jackson's. And we train every day
with him. And like I said, I never left.
And Greg asked me, he sat me
down after about, I don't know,
a couple of weeks of being there. He
said, man, I want you to be my 50 fiver.
And at that time he had the list of 55
hours were nuts that he had and I was
like, wow, fuck Greg Jackson,
who at the time was the man man,
right that the gym was
kind of 90% winning. Great.
And he just, he's such a
knowledgeable, awesome dude man.
And to see where the gym was
to where the gym is now is,
it's like heartbreaking
to me to be honest. And I,
and you want to talk about loyalty,
which is the biggest thing
in this conversation that
we're having right now is
how they pick someone over me
through being loyal. I stuck by Greg.
Even when the gym started going down,
when Winkeljohn merged over,
all of the big pros left. It turned
into like a puppy mill. You know,
it wasn't for, for back when Greg
had it and it was its own school.
You couldn't turn up to a pro class.
Like,
like some guy couldn't just come
here and knock on your door.
Like you say you get Weirdos hero time.
Next thing you know he has shin pads
on and sparring, there's litter,
be at the new gym,
bumps come in off the street,
I swear to God and we'll fight these and
we'll come in and put stuff on a fight.
That's a true story.
Random bums off the street and uh,
that would never happen back in the
day. So Greg doesn't run it anymore? No,
he has.
He's like,
so out of the loop Winkle John runs
the entire thing and that's what,
what is Greg doing? He kind of stepped
back for a couple of years, man.
Like kind of started doing other things
and just kind of got burned out I guess,
which is why I created the BMF ranch.
I needed somewhere to go and
something to do. So I created my list,
which is wings argument with me right
now saying you built your own place,
you don't ever come here bubba. I
said, why don't I ever come here?
Because usually the people you let
in here is outlandish. Like anybody,
you pay $150 you can get on the
masters and spar with Holly Holmes.
You know what I mean? That's,
that's what it's come to down there.
And back in the day it was like
private and just us and good pros.
Everyone there for the same mission,
trying to, trying to get better, you know?
But I've talked to some
other people that are,
I don't want to name sure they've
said that when they go down,
their new guys will come in and is
literally a fight is a fight. It's a,
there's no, there's no, there's
no a, B, c class anymore.
It's like literally these guys come in,
they want to make a name on it.
He was sometimes when you're
towards the end of a fight camp,
you don't need those new guy. You don't
need that crazy sparring. Right. Right.
You need, you need the guys you trust and
not some random guy, I don't know. Right.
So it's just, it's Asinine
me, man. What, what?
They turn that place into that.
That still happens and I'm a man because
you're never going to find that in
boxing. And boxing. All
sparring is control, control,
bringing the sparring partners,
you know who you're working with.
So I mean we've talked
loyalty again to me with Greg,
his name is on that building. It's
not, it's Wink Jackson wink, right?
Jackson fucking wink your names first.
Even when it came time to,
to pick a decision and they said,
we want to go with Perry.
Why the fuck didn't you stand? Because
Greg still with me. He's like, yeah,
I'll just come to the ranch and
we'll sort this out. And I'm like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
You tell me I can't come
into the Jackson wink gym,
but you're going to backdoor and come
to my fucking house and we're going to
train to fight me while
Perry's there at the gym.
You see everything he does and then
you're going to come and you're going to
train me. Not to mention you're holding
classes there and he's watching me.
You might not be training him to beat me,
but there's a lot of people there that
have trained with me for fucking years.
So, to me, that was the
point. I was saying like, man,
can we just not have him
there for this camp? I mean,
there's a lot of secrets that I, that
like inner secrets that I have, like, Yo,
I'm, I'm fucking scared to death to
fight. Like that's not to say he can,
they can tell him like, or they tell them,
you know, go get cowboy mad. You know,
he doesn't fight well when he's
pissed off. So fucking pissed him off,
poke out and poked the bear, piss
him off, get him out of his element,
give him the, you know, the
shit like this. Right. So,
and there's a lot of other things,
small,
dumb things that I do and tendencies
I've seen over over the year or 10. Yeah.
Right. Um, to me that's,
it's very intimate.
The relationship between a coach and
a fighter is, is very, very intense.
So for someone to violate that
in that way, and, you know,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with guys from a camp deciding to fight
each other and you've
got to work that out.
But for them to tell you
that you can't Carlos Condit,
I agree with you that we'll figure it out.
Right? Call us. You go that way. We'll,
right. These are your times. Your
hours affect each other. Right.
Friends trading partners who just came in,
I said I got nothing against Perry. He's,
he's looking for, he wants a home, right?
He's looking, he felt like Jackson does.
He's great. I like that. Go Up to him.
I mean, what is he going to do?
Right. And, and I just said, hey,
frank was going to go and train
with him wherever I heard stories.
He was looking to go to Vegas anyway.
I don't have any idea, man. I was just,
I was just like, man, can we
just not do it for this fight?
And then Winkeljohn
called me on the phone,
didn't you have the fucking balls or the
backbone to say it to my fucking face?
And I was right there with them,
called him on the phone. Like, Oh yeah,
we're actually going
to, oh, go with Perry.
You know he pays money. That's again,
it comes back to the money. I'm like,
so Perry pays him a percentage and you
don't pay Greg for my entire career I've
ever been there because I don't like
Winkeljohn style and like his way he holds
meds. I don't like the way he trains
people different about what he does.
It's the same thing for rep, for you. For
me, for John Sam, they're all the exalted.
It's the cookie cutter.
Everything's exactly the same
and it never changes. It's,
I don't understand how you can be a coach
of the one of the greatest at one time,
the greatest Jim's on the planet, you
know, and then don't ever revolve,
don't ever change and don't
run class and it, to me it's,
he just drove that place
into the ground, man. Turn,
literally turn it into a puppy mill.
It's only about making money
and for you guys at all,
I'm talking about a pug mill when someone
has a dog and they just fucking breed
it and sell puppies and breed it and
sell the puppies that that's what's
happening. The infrastructure of this
gym. Now let's talk about training there.
Let's talk about coaching,
right? Greg's supposed to be
the, the, the general right.
I'm just a soldier. How come I have
to be now a general anesthesia?
It's fucking up in my,
in my career. I can't,
I need somebody to tell me what to do.
Tell me what not to do.
And I had to start my own school at
the ranch, bringing my own coaches.
But then now I'm making all the
executive decisions when we're training,
what we're training, what we're doing.
And I'm not, I'm no longer just a soldier.
I'm having to fucking run
this whole thing. Um, that's
not mapping for fighters.
The problem for me too,
I liked it.
I'm a fucking super alpha male and I like
to communicate with my coaches and get
everything done in the guys that have a
fucking stand and by me and I love him
to death, but I need someone to be like,
you know what? You crazy fucking bastard.
You're going too hard going to do office
taper off. It's pumped. The brakes. Oh,
let's pick it up. Right.
The fucking fun fuck off.
Part of your life is taking
over into your training.
Can we step it up a little bit?
Right. I need that. I need,
I need fucking direction.
I need today we're working on this,
not just me going in there saying,
ah,
let's fucking wrestling
today. Right? So, um,
you know what to do, but it's also nice
for someone else who knows what to do,
who's completely objective is. Then
on the outside, because there's been,
I'm in this so long,
there's bright,
like I could literally Joe never spar
from now til the Perry fight and probably
not even do one Jujitsu role. And I
would be okay to fight like mentally,
but that's probably not a fair idea.
Right? Like you at your optimum.
Exactly. Um, so it's just,
it's fucking Asinine to me
and the coaches down there.
So not only can somebody just ring
the doorbell and show up and train,
pay the money. You pay the $25 a
drop in, or you paid 159 a month.
Come to any class you want. But if you're
a coach, you can just coach the class.
It's that.
It's that Asinine.
Do I see a new striking
coach or new wrestling coach
or new Jujitsu guy in there
twice a week probably,
and they're coaching the class.
Our rest main wrestling
coach of Jackson wink,
the greatest school in the fucking
world is a reception to a chiropractic
upstairs.
He's great as credentials.
Whereas he was a junior
assistant coach at a college,
don't know the college name, who got
fired for selling the kid steroids.
That's our wrestling coach.
I had one of the greatest schools in
the world is a good coach and it was
terrible. He's fucking
God awful, terrible.
He watches videos on Youtube and tries
to teach people things that don't even
fucking work.
It's Asinine,
which is another thing that I had to
hire my own coach and bring them in.
You know, it's like, it's like, Whoa,
wait, what? And now they don't even drill.
They just go live and they want to
know why people get hurt every day.
It's like you can't just go in and
say, okay, and we're wrestling go.
So do you think that people just get burnt
out on doing things the right way and
they just, they just figure, look,
I'm just going to do this the way that
makes the most money? Well, I think,
and I wish I had,
I had the answer for that.
I do because I'm not in that position to,
I'm not running a gym and that's,
I've never done that
because I don't want it.
Me showing up to class every single
day would wear me the fuck out.
Where's everybody?
Everybody's got to.
But you should have an infrastructure
set in place that takes, especially if
you're the greatest at one
time, right? If you're winning,
percentages are in the eighties and
nineties and now they're in the 20s like I
don't, I have no clue what our, what our
rating record of the gym is. But it's,
it's nothing like it used to
be. Right. And it's fucking,
it's Asinine to me the way you were doing
as a, you have the BMF ranch, right?
To have everything set up.
You bring in all your sparring partners
and you would be doing all your training
out there.
And how would Greg interact?
We do their show up down at
Jackson's and spar cause they sell,
they're still bodies down there.
Right.
There's still guys would
show up now as far.
We'd bring all the guys in or
Greg would come up, you know,
three or four times a week to the ranch
and we do as far as your ranch from 50
miles bell. Okay. Good Hour.
A solid hour drive into the
vast Nolan's of New Mexico.
Do you like living out there? I do.
I love it. I was fucking love it.
So I sold my house. I moved
here, I fucking planted roots.
Now I could never ever sell my place.
I'm stuck in New Mexico.
I'm moving back to Colorado.
I'm a buyer.
You never saw it because I have to
sell it to like a crazy cold leaders.
If anybody out there listening
also operate a cold right
now I have the perfect
alchemy about, we've
got 40 acres, 40 acres,
plenty of rooms, buildings,
animals in your vicinity.
Um, oh yeah. This might be
where we start. There's,
there's about an hour driving and
running some elk antelope, um,
everywhere.
Which is crazy thing about analog.
Did you know they don't jump fences,
they won't jump fences, right?
You can just literally cornered
him into a, into a, into a nail.
Occasionally jump a fence. They've been
known to jump a fence occasionally.
It was very, very rare. You know,
they evolved before the ice age.
They evolve to get away from
Cheetahs. Howard, you're so smart.
That's what I want to know. I'm
not smart. I just remember, dude,
it's fucking insane. There was a, a,
a mass extinction of a giant land mammals.
It's somewhere around 12,000 years ago
in North America and before then there
was cheetahs.
There was actual North American cheetahs.
There was a north of back in lion
that's bigger than the African lion.
How about that shit.
Giant ass fucking line and that's
where these fucking things did you want
another chu?
I saw it last time
I brought me Kevin, if you got Rogan
to fucking take a chill, just take it.
I swallowed it. I didn't know what
I was doing like a man. All right.
Round two.
Here we go to,
it's a wintergreen
Copenhagen under your chin.
Under your lip change if you want
it take just a little one too.
They
take a big hub or liver.
So there's that. Um, there's
turkeys out there. Target,
right? I love Turkey. I'm a
bird hunting fanatic man. Man.
I love birds. How many acres you
got? 40 acres. Oh Wow. It's nice.
40 acres and mule
but bird's eye look a bird junkie.
How'd you find that spot?
Um, so when I moved out
there and after I was in, um,
the gym for like a year and a
half of Leonard, I was like, Bro,
you're like winning a bunch of UFC fights.
Now I'm in the WC.
Uh, we're starting to get a little bit of
money. Let's get a house together, right?
Let's find a house.
So I started looking kind of in the
remote areas around where I knew I could
commute in, but I wanted somewhere I
could ride my dirt bike, shoot guns,
just be cowboy. And, um,
we found that place and I call
my grandpa and I said, hey,
I think I found a house. And
he said, I'll be right there.
And he and my grandma drove and he
walked to the lady and he handed her an
envelope full of cash and he said,
well take it
just like that. Wow. Yeah.
It was probably 60 or 70,000 less than
they're asking, but he had real cash,
real cash and said,
we'll take it.
One grandson wants it and um,
Wow. And I was like, oh, I
was just showing like, okay,
uh, thanks grandma. Right.
Like we just bought me a house and um,
he liked,
believes in me no matter what I
did. I used to be on, on magician.
I used to like love my magic,
right.
So He'd always behind me magic shit
and sit there and watch me do it.
And he was such a fucking cool
dude, man. He used to do magic.
[inaudible] did you ever do shows?
No, no, no. I mean I was like 12, 13.
I would do shows to my grandma,
Grandpa,
and my friends and I still have
like a toolbox full of magic stuff.
I should busted out and bring it out here
one time. And there's some cool, yeah,
I'm not like good, like
you wouldn't be like, Whoa,
Doug blue one. But there's some, some of
that slide of hand stuff. It's pretty fun.
And like the coin coin magic is good.
And how do you keep the shift from
going in your mouth? You just,
cause it doesn't for me,
it doesn't seem to want to stay put
where you keep drinking on top of it.
You've got to like very with
your tongue and then go over it.
Try fucking love it. So yeah. Um,
greatest dudes, man taught
me a lot, taught me a lot
about loyalty, respect man.
And, and I called my grandma on
my way here today and I said,
I'm going to fucking set fire
to this bridge to Jackson's.
And she wrote me back and said,
what you need to like,
are you attacking them logically
or are you out of anger? Which,
which direction are we going here?
Powerful grandma right on the ball.
What's direction? How
are we going? And uh,
she said and start bidding
soon, Huh? Yeah, you definitely
got to spit. She said,
make sure you know always in life,
don't ever paint yourself into a corner.
Like these are major lessons you
always do and we don't burn bridges.
You can't cross.
But she told me today fucking and
let it go. Let them have it. They,
they, they want to step across the
line. They drew the line in the sand,
let them want to burn their own,
make them just feel so bad.
They want to burn their own fucking gym
to the route. And you know, it's like,
to me having the moment for Greg
to say, you know what, wink,
my name's on this fucking Jim Cowboy
has been with me from the star.
There's been times two or three camps
ago where I've trained Greg maybe one or
two times and I still write him a check.
I still write them a check and I
pay him because he got me into this
motherfucker and loyalty to me. Is that
the top, top of the line thing, right?
It's top of the line to me too.
That's why you're here. Right?
That's why they're not.
And you know,
and it's unfortunate because I would like
Greg a lot and I, and I was like, great.
I don't know much about Winkeljohn
other than his work. Right.
What does on with Holly and
a lot of other people and uh,
I was really torn up about this. That's
why I contacted you. Sure, sure. You know,
when you told me this is like a crazy
scenario all around for everybody across
the board, like, wait, what do you
like? What, what the fuck you mean,
what's happening here? You know, and
it's, it's, it's crazy. It's wild. I
appreciate you sticking by my side.
It was a, it was a situation where I
didn't know what to do. Yeah. You know?
I was like,
I can't just ignore it.
I would have to bring it up when they
were here and then I wouldn't get a full
representation of it. Sure. I mean, do
you feel like you had a full revenue,
you got to figure out how to
do this right? It's a skill.
You learn how to Tuck it in your,
yeah, that's all over the place.
It's in my mouth. My was in a little ball
right here. I don't know. Mine is not,
uh, is not controlled. I'm going
to wind up swollen this again.
So if your name's on the,
on the thing,
like right now you go
to put a spit it out.
Now you've got to open another beer and
wrench it and you got to give it a ranch.
I said Reggie, I opened bare
rent it out. Spit it out.
That way you don't get any more
swollen though. You're not sick again.
I wasn't sick last time. It was fine. It
was weird. I swallowed the whole thing.
Um, fuck yeah, I missed you man.
I missed Ya. It's been a
while. So much has happened.
I'm glad we got that kind of out of
the way. I'm sure I'll circle back on.
I drink a little bit more.
I'm sure it's too, it's um,
it's unfortunate and I know what it must
be like to try to keep the lights on in
a big gym and now they have dorms. It's
huge. Giant ass place. Huge overhead.
I'm sure all of these people
coming in, coming out, and then,
you know how fighters are not you,
but some fighters,
they don't give a fuck about loyalty.
They just care about themselves.
They're on their path.
It's a,
it's a very solitary single shelf
that you're very selfish sport.
You kind of have to be right.
Yeah.
And I think that's Kinda where
the team got was very selfish.
He has his own gym now. I
had to fucking hat too, man,
for the better of my family and me.
I had to keep evolving.
I couldn't spiral down this drain
with you guys. Right. You know,
now Michelle Waterson
just build a new gym.
She's doing the same thing in her
backyard. Love her to death, you know,
not doing it to her. And her husband
built a badass little jam. Oh Wow.
All sponsored by on it. Fucking
really bitching man. It's
cool. Yeah. Good for her.
Good. Yeah. Michelle Wu. Um, you know,
but if you look at the track records,
since [inaudible] has taken over
the gym, everyone's left. I mean,
it's like you don't see a
pattern here, wink. Like,
maybe you should change
something up or just not allow,
he's been fighting for a long time.
Shannon training for a long time.
I mean,
he was a bad ass kickboxer before he
ever got into training. And you know,
I think one of the things that happens
with people, they just get this holes,
selfishness of the sport.
It wears people down to a certain extent.
There's comradery,
but there's also selfishness and they're
all constantly going against each other.
Sure. And you know, having a gym like
that, the expenses, the overhead,
and then, you know, dealing
with people that are just
grabbing, grabbing, grabbing.
It's just, it's got to get overwhelming.
And you see a guy like Mike who, you
know is a potential big star. He's a
colorful kid. He's a knockout artist.
He fucking loves to fight. If
I was a coach, I'd be like,
this is the kind of guy I want in my gym.
He's a fucking animal. You know, it's, uh,
it's a show.
We're excited to fight him because this
is the one of those fights where we're
going to go in the middle of
the ring and we're going to,
we're going to fucking fight the old
school. Fucking yeah, let's fight.
So I'm fucking, I'm pumped on it. I
love the kid, you know, he's cool.
He's crazy. Him and I would get
along. Just going to do so. Uh,
I got nothing. Like I said, nothing
the ham or Frank Frank is Koetsu.
Well that's Perry's working with,
with frank,
the on striking coach who Frank Lester
Lester who was holding, holding the,
the infrastructure of the gym together.
Almost single handedly.
You know,
there's a couple of wrestling guys and
I'm his Brandon Gibson still random.
Brennan had a full time job. He just got
promoted again in his government job.
He was like a real government
job. Job, job, job on top
of being a super chocolate.
Yeah. How the fuck they do
that man, I have no idea.
He has like a nine to nine to six job,
maybe,
maybe seven to six job.
Really these every morning up early take
care of his family. He's a great dude.
I got nothing bad, nothing
but love for branding. Gibson,
man, nothing that really,
him and I just separated
only because I need to,
I just want a different angle of striking.
It wasn't,
it would mean we had nothing to do
with, he's a bad coach. I lost my fight.
I'm firing you. It's just fucking
just trying something new,
trying something new, that's all.
Uh, but yes, gives it to them,
but with Gibbs and kind of just
works, you know, with John Dodson,
with condit Kinda,
I mean,
he doesn't have the time to go in there
and just hold that gym together. So he,
um, he has a real job and he
just got another promotion.
So he's like the top of the,
he started off as a lifeguard,
worked his way all live in the city.
Now he's damn near governor.
I think that's next governor
is next for getting that hard.
I had Gary Johnson in here. I think
I can be governor of New Mexico. No,
no offense, Gary. Well, let's legalize
pot and a mushroom. Is it not legal there?
It's, it's recreation or I mean
it's um, medical diamonds. Yeah.
One of those places.
This is a lot of places
we got of AIDS like that.
That's how it used to be a lot of places.
But like Vegas used to be like that and
now big, this is Lucy goose open wide.
Vegas got full on dispensary's
man fucking Vegas Man.
Vegas is definitely a two night town
man. Yeah, it's rough on the liver.
It's rough on everything. It just takes
you, it takes you the fuck in man. Yeah.
I was just there last night.
I was out there for a big monster
conference and it's just like you,
you sit in your room,
you're like,
well I could just go down
and a gamble I guess.
And then you start gambling. Have you
ever played backer rod? I don't put shit.
I have never either. And I decided, we
tried backer rod like double oh seven.
I was like, we'll be like double o
seven. We'll go in there. I played with,
with one of the higher ups in monster
and he took us down and we played this
game and uh, fuck, we
want a shit load of money.
A shitload of money. There was like five
trek. Yeah. Yeah. I'll take some of that.
I'm really smoke much pot,
but I know just talking with you,
that stuff was that they grew up out
on the moon. I saw a video of him,
breakdancing, it, any breakdowns.
What I do, I used to, I
used to really break down.
So I had the Mazda conference.
We lose a Blackstone.
I met the monster conference and um,
monster now has a break dancing team.
Yes. Monster got me some bags.
Bags, man. A good dude, man.
He's a great dude. Yeah.
He uh, he takes care of,
he takes care a lot of people and the
infrastructure of monster. Great. Right.
Great instructor. Monster. Yeah. So
the ambassador Hauns takes care of it.
Take care of people. Right. So, uh,
I seen the are going to tell you,
I seen the moms, your babies laying
back there fucking, I just got them. Um,
Gustin Bolanos it was his idea. So the
more that you're gonna get crazy. Okay,
let's start talking about space soon.
Doing drugs.
A Joe, it's not nature
nature, man. I'm with Ya.
Um,
so the break dancers,
they start break dancing and then
halfway through their show they stop it.
Oh yeah. So they set up a battle
between me and this other guy. Right.
And he's had to go out here
and we have to break dance.
I used to break dance back in years ago,
but on a slippery floor with cowboy
boots and I did that properly stretch.
Yeah. That's good. Oh, so fun man. I
it boots Mazda shirt getting down, doing
a little breakdowns and it was so fun,
man.
Dude,
we have a bunch of guys from 10th planet
that started out as breakdancing. Uh,
Geo Martinez,
one handed push up with your foe,
one handed hand stand with your feet
up in the end, twist them around.
That's crazy control of your body.
It was, it's like yoga on steroids.
It's so hard.
It's so hard as it's even harder to do.
After 12 years of never even doing it
again and go with cowboy boots all go.
Here we go.
We had a bus of these guys come in and uh,
Eddie called me up and he gets crazy.
He goes by dancing like dancing.
Dancing is to think. It's the thing.
These guys are so fucking strong,
I can even control them.
Break Dancers, man.
These guys are like 140
pounds and they're like,
it's like holding onto a
live wire. Yeah, there's,
they're so strong.
And what does that guy's name?
Bboy pocket Kim is that his name is,
what is his name?
I put him on my Instagram way back in
the day. This is Korean kid. That is,
it doesn't even seem like a
human can do what he does.
That's how I felt yesterday when this
has been dancing. I was like, Hey,
spins all on one hand he's on one hand
hopping up and down in the air and spin
it around and you're like, pocket
Kim. Yeah. Watch this motherfucker.
This guy is such a beast.
It's crazy to walk.
There's a bunch of these guys now they're
con there's, there's a stance elements.
Yeah. What could this motherfucker
look at? This mother fucker.
I mean what the fuck is he doing?
It's called air tracks. Right?
Is Quick on air tracks and
he's laying right there.
That's that. It's crazy. Yeah.
It's like flaring in the air that
that is damn near impossible to do.
That guy is three cause
their trick of all freaks.
It's crazy what he could do and
there's a few of those guys.
If you go to that stance elements,
click on that stance elements. Jamie,
the these guys are,
there's,
I didn't know about this until a
Tim Ferriss put it on his Instagram.
He put pocket Kim on and then
I went and watched these guys.
These guys are doing just insane
physical acrobatics along with music,
but I feel like the kids now are doing
insane. Everything. Snowboarding, dirt,
biking Jitsu, everything. Everything is
on a whole nother level playing field,
right? Yeah. They're dead. MMA fighters.
These young guys that are coming in are,
are not just solely one one discipline.
Right. They have everything there.
MMA fighters.
You're seeing these new gut like Zup
beat is one of my favorite guys to watch
Zombie Magomed Sharapov say
that five times he's he,
he, it's like these new high level guys
are coming in and you look at it and be
like, oh, okay. We just
hit the new evolution.
There's a new evolution going on
with these young guys coming up.
It's fascinating. It will be, but that's
to be expected, right? With everything.
I guess especially with social media,
you get to see these guys,
like on Instagram you get to see the
moves at that guy's doing and all these
other break dancers get to see it.
They would have to see it live
rather seeing it in Korea,
they're seeing an in Japan,
they didn't have to travel and they're
seeing these moves and you slowed down.
We watch it and learn, learn. Right.
Crazy time and not only,
not only do we get to watch,
but we also get the shit
ass guide in his basement.
They get to talk shit about that.
You have is a little bit of that a lot.
There's a lot of it that can't
pay attention to that cow. I it,
it burns my soul too. Good to
pay attention to that. I hate,
I wish I was too good to say that,
but I get,
it's just like if I was coming here
and someone out in the parking lot said
something to me, I said, what the fuck?
Who the fuck you talking to you like that?
You know, like we'd have a, it'd be a
moment there. Yeah. Oh yeah. For sure.
That's how I still feel today. But
um, well that's why your cowboy. Yeah.
That's why you are who you are. To
help you a little bit of this. Yes.
The new mood, new MOU that the super new,
super new, super new mood case of it.
A real new moon. That's it.
That's a gift from me to you.
I'm talking more about your, um, your,
your buddy Paul Paul Stamets. I'll
stand, miss enlight fuck. Okay, let's,
let's back this up. Let's back it all to
take this, take this train back. Yeah,
just a little bit. Okay.
So you speaking about DMT.
Okay. Let me look back up.
One more. One more beep.
I've never done any drugs in my entire
life. Did a lot of drugs are here already.
I know we're back up.
Remember, we're backed up.
I've never done any drug, ever. Never,
ever use this. Two years ago. Oh,
you did lose the one that's
the best legal. Oh, legal
law. Um, you're a product of drugs
and products of drugs. Cherry.
This is not a pharmacy. Fantastic
truck. It's made for great jokes.
Fun Times, right? How many fucking
people had because of Budweiser,
Budweiser. So good drug.
Well regulated. You know, you know what
one bottle does? That's why I like,
you know, one bottle does, makes you
want it to, right? But that's you.
That's on you man. One bottom. You
have some Goddamn self control.
One bottle. You know what a bottle of
Budweiser does. It's really clear true.
It's like you eat a fucking pot Brownie
who, it could be anything you know,
you could be, who knows the fuck
you're getting to get that limit.
And you tell everything is
3.2% poor people in Utah,
you know they're rebranding,
rebranding. I found out this last
night, they don't call Mormons anymore.
Erik Griffin was telling me,
calling the Mormon Mormon.
It's like calling a small person a
midget. Yup. What do you call it?
A latter day saints. Shout out to the
latter day saints. Magic underwear.
Magic underwear. So no drought. Okay.
No drugs talk.
You hear you're talking about DMG.
Everyone's on is DMT ride just sponsored
by this little company called on it,
which is now fucking huge company,
which I love by the way. The gut health.
Oh yeah. Probiotics mess. My favorite.
You eat Kimchi or anything like that?
Do you ever eat? No. You should.
You should get it. Get involved. Get
getting involved with some probiotics,
you know, um, uh, Kiefer's really
good. Kim. Choose really good.
Now your people are in Buckeye. You're
talking about your diet again. Ah Man.
It's good to, it's good.
People need to know like,
you gotta take care of your internal, you
know, you don't see that gut health man,
but it affects your depression,
your mood. The way your brain works,
where your immune system
functions got helps everything.
Those little Onnit packets
are key. Man, I don't,
I don't travel without those pitches.
I don't go a day without them.
I ate on my or new pack and
they got a new package for them.
Now they're not in the same
old box. More high tech. Cool.
They exist on the substrate that's in
those capsules. That's one of the ways,
the ways you don't have to refrigerate
it so good for travel because it's just,
I think you should have
a variety of probiotics,
but I think it's one of the most critical
things that people don't think about
anyway. Anyway, drugs, drugs,
drugs. Aubrey said, hey,
why don't you come out? We got a
little group, people doing some DMT.
Did he do the whole ceremony?
She loves music. Chanced.
Erica rose every the whole thing.
We smoked tobacco out by the fire.
I'm going play some of that acre.
Rose,
you're talking about talking about
what direction we wanted this to go.
You know what?
What we wanted the journey to consist of,
I call them my
best friends up. Take them with me
and we'd go out there and we fucking,
we do this,
we sit in this room and we go through
the chance in the ceremony and I'm scared
it because I've never done anything right.
Scared, scared, never done anything.
I wish that's it.
Waking,
waking up the spirits.
You just have that last year. It's on.
Oh Dude, this is just gonna make me trip.
So if I listened to this,
if I eat a pot Brownie,
listen to this and getting the tank,
I'll start trippin
all right.
It's because when you do DMT and you're,
you hear this stage dance for you, right?
So the, the experience,
you realize what this is.
This is like a technology to maximize DMT.
And while while you're on this GMT,
this is playing in the background,
trying to drum and chance and yeah,
that's right. That's what's going
on. I was in a super smoothly,
my camera room I guess,
but it was
rather a nice,
okay.
He knows what the fuck is. Know what
the fuck he's doing. The real way.
You'd be a beautiful man,
really spiritual in the room.
He might be a beautiful man,
beautiful body,
and it looks like he's running a sex cult.
But what he really is doing is doing it
the right way to say it looks like the
gentleman Lee doing it the right way.
I can maybe sell the ranch to Aubrey
and sex called RB and I are partners.
We'll talk after this podcast.
So I just need to know what kind of
zone and you have and whether or not you
have water on the property. Go.
I have why you gotta well wow.
Two wells actually. So
what happened? All right,
so this music plan and they load the pie,
which to me looked like pink
cocaine, right? Like pink guts.
And they load it and
this pipe and he says,
just light it and you want to breathe
fresh air out of the corner of your mouth
as you're taking this harsh smoke.
It smells like burning plastic.
It's harsh. It's just hit it,
do you can't anymore. I'm like,
what the fuck does that mean? I try going
to hit this rubber, hit it, I hit it.
And then all of a sudden I say, oh,
you hit it until you can't anymore.
And he starts getting wavy and then I
just the pipe balls out house and I fall
back. The entire world comes
back zooming in and be like
black and I shoot do this
fucking kaleidoscope of colors,
maybe 10 seconds and blow out the top
like superman out of the top of this tube
of colors,
it's total black darkness and I'm looking
at myself from my the third person.
I'm just hovering in midair and everywhere
that I've ever been injured or hurt
it glowing, bright like super white, like
the whitest white fire I've ever seen.
Like my head's on fire arms is this or
like something out of a fucking movie.
I'm just suspended in the air burning
and I keep asking myself questions
and then I don't know if it's me,
but I answered her back to myself.
Right.
I'm bugging the fuck up because you
could still hear this music going.
I can hear the people giggling next to me,
I can hear the next guy lighting the
lighter and he's now going and meanwhile
I'm is burning and I'm talking to myself
about whatever question I answered
right. And then all of a sudden, just as
fast as I came in, I kind of eyes woken.
I woke up and I still see the rest of
the guys in the room cause they like
systematically go around the
room and an order they're in,
they're in there and she hits.
Now the pipe comes around again
and now it's my turn again.
Now I'm really excited.
I almost wish halfway through the trip
you could fucking hit it again and go
back in. So I hate, and this
time I'm thinking, yeah,
I want to go back to that again.
I want to go back to where I just was.
So I fucking hate the pipe. Hit the
pipe, hit the pipe. Now I hit the pipe.
So God damn hard not hold my breath.
I fall over to the side,
I flied out ball to my left
side and I've tipped over. Well,
I sit back up because you're still there,
right?
You're not like in another dimension.
You're not out of your body experience.
So I sit back up for the entire trip
now is sideways and I'm looking at my,
this trip,
I'm looking at it crazy black rainbows
and I can explain what a fuck a black
rainbow looks like,
but they're waving with sparkles and black
into a keyhole that's turned sideways
and through a key hole,
a crazy light shapes and darts.
And every time I almost get to this key
hole, it just sucks back more something.
I've got to move that joy and
I crawled through it again.
I tried to get to the key hole and he
sucked back again and there was no words
spoken.
This one is me just trying to get to
this sideways keyhole and I just get my
hand to crawl through it and they would
fucking take off again and I woke up and
that was
who's my DMT experience. You've only
done it once? I'm only not at one time.
I want to do it again. Yeah, you need
to do, yeah, just marijuana. Okay.
Done the Doug about marijuana
being a gateway drug. Um,
no.
DMT is a gateway drug for me.
What's the gateway drug to it allows you
to do other drugs and now I do a lot of
mushrooms.
Well,
it's one of those things where it lets
you know that all your ideas about what
drugs are, are out the window, right?
All your ideas are all your
ideas about what reality is,
are out the window because you didn't
think that this was a part of reality.
How could anybody ever think it before
you experienced it? But what I don't
get as things that shit shapes
and colors that I couldn't almost,
that you don't see today where I could
see him there and I could have exploded
like the shapes in the movements. It
was just so weird. Like you're right.
Like reality is like what the fuck?
How has that reality? And it seems
more vivid than reality, more
vivid.
But the chord that I'm going
to tell people are listening.
Like you can just open
your eyes, right? I mean,
you would be real hazy and kind of gone,
but I can hold my eyes.
I could see the candles
burning over there.
I could hear her lighters going and
then you're like, oh, I'm, I'm okay.
I'm not in another dimension. You're
going to get stuck in this crazy world.
And then how to close my eyes and
not go back into it. And Yeah.
I mean it's like the most of the realist
dream you've ever seen, right? Yeah.
There's another one called
five Meo DMT five methoxy DMT.
And it's a, is that the only room
tonight does a different way. The dial,
that one makes people really scared.
That's a different one because you see
you cease to exist on that one. Right.
It's more powerful, actually.
More, more potent. Yeah.
Which is crazy to think there's
something more potent and Dmt,
but it's more psychoactive in some ways.
And it's a,
it's one of those weird ones
that doesn't have visuals either,
but you just go to, you go to
everything, you go to heaven,
you become a part of it all.
It's crazy how clear.
Yeah.
And since you could make
of the uncensored, right?
Like I try to explain now on it, it
sounds weird, but when I was in it,
everything's so clear.
Yeah.
Well you realize how much of what's
holding you back in this life is like
insecurity and fear and, and, and it just,
it just not knowing, you know, and,
and confusion and all this and then it
just sort of like pours water on the
stuff that's dirty and clean out all the
bullshit out and goes no, it's all love,
happiness, friends, experiences,
live, camaraderie. Those
are the important things.
That's that you have a party,
you have a chance in this life to spread
more of that and help other people
spread more than keep this ball rolling.
And that could really change the world,
the change the world because the people
that you impact ripple out and they,
they impact other people.
Or You could just get caught up in
arguing with people online. You know,
you can get caught up,
get caught up in the water over the
dirt and just the chaos of it all.
It doesn't take much to get me caught up.
So what,
that's also why you're a great fighter.
You know, those things go hand in hand.
If you're a person just accepted bullshit.
Maybe you wouldn't be the guy that gets
up in the morning when you don't want to
give. You wouldn't be the guy that takes
those fights on short notice. He goes,
fuck it. Maybe you'd be the guy
that would be like, you know what?
This is not the right move for my
career. I have to sit back, have to,
you're not a, you're a, you're a wild
man. And that's why people love you.
But that's also, that needs to be
kind of, it seems to be appreciated,
but also managed,
right?
Like the chaos of your personality
and how you approach things. I mean,
you almost fucking died in the
caves, bro. This is what you do.
That's my other drug. Adrenaline.
Yeah. You got adrenaline. It,
uh, the things that people
were scared of, you flock to,
it's like you want to prove that
you're not scared of him. And I am.
I'm just as scared as you are. Sure. I
skydiving. I love it because it's like,
Ooh. Yeah. And we go, yeah, there's
no, there's no if, ands or buts.
And you jump out of a fucking plane.
I'm flying planes now.
Get my pilot's license. I'm putting, I've,
I started a little while back. I quit for
a while, but now I'm back. I'm all in.
I'm flying and I'm loving it,
man. I'm just telling you.
I watch that Leonard Skinner documentary
last night. Don't, don't fly.
Shit he played. That's how
we lost lives. Skinner.
They didn't need it to get
their fucking plane fixed.
Trout fuck is true fucking pill heads,
man.
Two years I come back, I'll be
flying. I'll fly up. Fly out here.
Yeah man. So, so wild man.
So that's a bold movement. I
learned how to fly. I mean,
that's the ultimate right.
Drinking beer with you.
But it is easy to brother little campfire
where you fucking said we're slicing
dear. You should definitely
do that. One of these days.
You should come to us till the night
with us. Okay. You would love it, man.
It's the craziest hunting ever,
and it's like one of the most ethical,
you have to kill him. 30,000
deer on this one island. No,
20,000 deer and 3000 less touch that
little subject for a minute about,
we now have to kill these animals.
Why?
Because there's so many people that
are like, fuck you hunters. What? Why?
Why would you want to
take a life? Yeah. Well,
the alumni is a different example because
it's an island to island filled with
deer and there's no wolves
and there's no mountain lions.
People have to eat them. They're fucking
everywhere. Yeah, because if they don't,
there's going to throw over
populated. Yeah, of course. Yeah.
But I mean, I think
the, the hunting thing,
the anti honey thing is probably real
similar to what we're talking about with
psychedelic drugs. It's people who
haven't experienced it. They don't,
they don't know what it really is and
they, a lot of them still, I mean,
97% of the people in this country
eat meat. I'm one of them.
That's a crazy number.
When you think about how many
people get hated on for hunting.
That means for sure some of those
people that are hating also eat meat,
which is one of the most crazy
up ocracy he's ever crazy,
right? I mean when you
look at it like that. Yeah,
with the numbers because they are like,
they as they're eating their
hamburger on the same breath,
there's telling you what a piece of shit
you are for killing ducks. Yeah. Yeah.
And it's disconnection. You think vegans,
if a mosquito lands on them, do they,
do they slap it and kill
it about that all the time?
Do they kill mice that are nibbling in
the corner of their house and making
noise or they can't sleep? They said
a mouse trap house. Good question.
Did they shoot the fly with the bad ass
new salt fucking shot call of this shit.
Me, I'm picking them bitches
off. I even met, I open the door,
I let him left him in from the horse.
Shit come on.
And boy that got a little blue
black and doing hair flap.
So, uh, yeah, they, I mean,
just some of them does a mosquito
or a fly and not have a soul.
I went to an Osram once and uh, the
lady had a ant spray out. I was like,
what are you doing with that? She's like,
oh, we have an ant problem. Here I go,
you got an amp problem. Here
I go see killed with the
spray. That's fucking crazy.
This is ash. Rob is a Buddhist Ashram
and you are spraying ant spray.
You're poisoning deaths from the sky,
from the sky.
Fucking air warfare on these poor little
beings. Cause you don't like that.
They get too close to your
garbage. Hey, heavy. It's heavy.
It's crazy.
When you put in perspective like that,
they don't have an answer
doing wash yourself.
What about all those
microbiome on your body?
You killing all that shit with soap.
What are you doing?
What are you doing every
time you wash your asshole?
It's a holocaust killing all this
life forms, right? Right. No,
no if, ands or buts. Every, I
mean it just about her of what La.
And the other problem is there's real
evidence that somehow or another plants
communicate with each other that they
have some sort of an, if not awareness,
they have some sort of a information
exchange between each other and they
changed their taste based on whether
or not other ones are getting eaten.
It activates certain responses in the
plants and then they become like really
bitter and disgusting to animals so
that animals don't eat them. You know,
and they do this with like,
they can have a recording,
they can play recording of caterpillars
eating leaves next to a plant and it'll
change it's flavor profile and
excrete some sort of a chemical.
So the same discourages predation there.
There's some intelligence
evolving, right? Having to, it's
like, Ooh, Ooh, we're, we're, we're,
we're no longer going to exist
if this happens. We have to,
we have to evolve with the change,
which you talk about us becoming who
we are today from super primates to,
to write.
And I think now we're at cotton,
an error where the weak are
still allowed to coexist with us.
Yeah.
This a little bit of that.
But yeah, you laugh at that,
but it's true. Yeah, it's true.
And I just had a baby boy and I can't
wait to stand on the sidelines of the
soccer games and football games
and I can't wait to show up the fucking
track day and I'm bringing fucking
medals and trophies because my kid is
not getting the fucking participation
ribbon. He's here to win. Right.
When do we draw the line
back of of you don't just,
just because you are weaker,
you get participation ribbon.
There's no more competition and
no understanding of psychology.
You can't protect people from
bad feelings like losing those.
That's what propels you. That's what
makes you better. That's what we're,
that's what they're doing. So you're
telling you if my kids are awesome,
awesome football player and he's
on the team running touchdowns,
he has to sit the bench because
Tommy didn't get enough time to play.
And not only that,
Tommy,
you're his weak ass dad who fucking
secret emails the coach behind my back.
You know what I mean? Like
that shit to me. What the fuck?
So I can't,
I'm so excited to join this
new new journey of parenthood.
Parenthood. It's so
crazy, man. These kids,
and this is not all parents though,
you know,
some parents realize how stupid it is.
There's parents out there just like you.
Sure. Just like this is ridiculous.
This is a guy that's uh, his,
his daughter goes to school
with my daughter and uh,
I always gravitate towards him because
he's got a neck tattoo and immediately
I'm like,
anybody with a neck tattoo,
I'll relate to this because
that's a life decision
tat you mother fucker.
We gonna be all right because we're
where I don't have a neck tat,
but I know how you're
living so I'm with Ya.
And with these kids were playing
rough and he looked at me, he goes,
whatever happened to like getting hurt,
whatever happened to like falling down
and learn how, oh well it should do that.
That hurts. Yeah. Well know.
Learn how to fall better now.
Learn how to not do that
anymore. Well, this,
this thing was going to make you slip
and scuff your needs. Okay? Yeah.
That's part of learning.
You can't nerf the world.
You can't nerf the fucking
world when you nerf the world.
And then you empower these people that
have lived in a nerve to environment,
that's a problem. They'd
have an experience, real
adversity. And they're mean.
One of the reasons why their
mean it's cause they're
scared. Yeah. A lot of these,
these people on social
media that are really mean,
they're the ones who are the most scared
and they're the ones who are the most
week for sure.
And the fact that they're so vulnerable
is what's leading them to lash out and
try to hurt other people because
they're so easy to hurt and damaged.
I mean that's, that's literally the,
the results of living in a nerfed world.
But these people that you say or so he,
how was that satisfying them to
disable somebody that it's not,
they don't know what to do.
They're hurting and they just lash out of,
how are they writing an email?
Like I'm gonna get this motherfucker
sand and they're like, Ooh.
And then they see this, what
that is gratifying for them.
They're like, not even,
it seems like it would be because
they're just, they're trying to hurt you.
They're trying to like get you, but then
eventually it comes back and gets them.
It's like they have to understand
Lebron James isn't doing that. No,
no. Winners are out there doing
that. This is loser behavior.
Like you're lashing out at others
who are doing while you're not,
unless there's like,
if you have a legitimate problem
with someone talking about Lebron,
like in the NBA,
they don't just sit him down because
the other player 22 hasn't gotten enough
play time. No, no. The fuck I go ahead and
score again. Can we with you right here,
make some money, right? It's
good. It's good in the, we're
paying to watch on TV, but
when your kids in it, I don't get it
man, but I haven't experienced yet.
I've only had friends who
have fucking so excited to.
It's fascinating just to watch them
evolve, watched it a little minds grow,
watch talking to them.
You know,
just experiencing life through these
new eyes and seeing them learn.
It'll be a little fighter.
He's a rotten of a bitch.
He sleeps with his hands up and
this sleeps with his hands up,
both hands up. Oh, what are you
doing? And he was like, flex is out.
And he'll put them back and he
flexes his him out. And I'm like,
what are you doing man? It's so cool.
It's this little jumper and he has to,
he has blue frog and this red fish and I
don't know what this red fish did. Damn.
But that motherfucker would just
slide sideways and just look, stank.
I'm out for just sit there and stare
at him. 20 minutes, no movement,
no crime, just slouched over. And
he and he core parents of this red,
this red fish. And I'm like, what do,
what are you doing? And He, you know,
and I'll like,
and I'll spin and like play with them
and then he just finds him again,
just has a staring contest with
this fucking thing. Hilarious.
His practice practicing practice
it. And Ah, I think that's,
it definitely carries on
through the child. It has to
write, has to, has to, I mean,
there's only, there's things that
people learn like, well, why kids?
Scared of monsters. Well, you
don't have to be careful of
predators. Yeah. You know,
there's, there's lessons you learn,
you see things that are scary.
Like why do people have like
a fear of snakes? Oh yeah.
The barriers is the last one. Oh,
we've got a whole shelf. Perfect. Okay.
There's boy wants to go down. It's so
smooth. They do go down so smooth. Yeah.
I think for sure that some of your
personnel and it's going to be transferred
through your DNA. Do you have
life lessons? God, I can't
wait man. I'm so excited.
Yeah.
It's so cool to see.
See Him and how early are you gonna start
training them right away so it never
knows anything else. He, he,
not only Joe is he not gonna,
he's not gonna know anything else, but
we're dirt bike in work, wakeboarding,
word fucking scuba dive in.
We're every crazy thing I do.
He's going to do it and he shouldn't be
fucking launch and huge air and you got
to get around his other kids and he's just
kind of think that's just what you do.
Oh, you guys don't do that. Oh,
that's out of doing that for five years.
He won't know any different.
And um, yeah, I'll,
I'll definitely train him in wrestling
and Jujitsu and kickboxing. Absolutely.
Absolutely. And I'm going to be the dad
when he goes and eats a kid up at school.
I'm like, what? Danger you fucking animal.
How can aim is danger.
Your son's name is [inaudible].
My name is Donald [inaudible], so his
name's Dac. My initials and then son.
So he's my son.
Dangerous Serone DAX and dangerous.
Serone I'm gonna say Gauger
what are you doing it here?
You can't beat these kids up.
And as soon as we get in the hallway,
fucking fist bump or whatever
you want, boy, let's go. Well,
you already have evidence now on
video. Got to go. You need to watch
this video now. I mean that's if,
if, if he's in there, you know,
defendant his or doing whatever he has to
do, I'm with him. Yeah. Get you some boy.
Well going to the world going to be
like just 10 years. Yeah. When he's,
think about how weird it
is from 10 years ago. How,
where's it going to a timber and my high
school we had beepers. That's right.
Beepers.
Remember when people had beepers that
also could send text messages and like
what the fuck you take it too far.
And I had a,
you can leave a voice message on mine.
You could talk about whether you
can call us and do it, but yeah,
I mean these kids, your kids are, have
no idea what it is to pass a note,
write or call. Um, uh,
Mr um, Mr Rogan, um, how was,
I was just wondering if I could
talk with Sarah. Would that be cool?
It's after nine o'clock. Idiot.
Click that after nine o'clock deal.
Right. You have to know what
time you called. Texted them.
Bad precedent picture taken.
But I think the picture taken is also
taken a lot away from life. Like even me,
I get caught in and I'll go to lunch
with three of my friends and two minutes
into the lunch we're all Instagram
who's road and got on the show today.
You know? I know it's,
it is a problem. You,
you lose a lot of your life
to these fucking things.
A lot of it and it sucks you in.
But it's also so awesome because
so much is learned. Like you said,
it needs to be managed and
you and like that's in rice.
People you want to talk about.
We were just discussing the different
kinds of releases on the bow. Right?
Well maybe I don't know about you. I
literally, two seconds after I leave you,
I can youtube it and I can,
I can, you know it all, I
can know it all. It's crazy.
I can have experts on
every single release,
make Rolland judgment and decide what I
want to do. And that's crazy nowadays,
you know,
and that's,
the world is so much better in a
sense I think because you can do that.
But it takes away a lot of the
bullshit people used to have.
Do you probably when you were in school
and the guy tells you, I'm this, this,
this and this. Yeah. There's no
buddy goes other than Jimmy saying,
Oh yeah, I was there. Yeah. Right.
Yeah. He never knew. No. Now you
just go ahead like, wait, what?
Nah, man. That uh, yeah,
that's, that's negative view.
You are not a gold medalist and I write,
well,
you still see some of those
guys are still floating around.
This is a few of those guys are still
floating around that somehow or another
made it through the net and then the dark,
they came in and the dark net
floating around right now,
like kind of like skating on the
boundaries of incredulity was,
yeah.
There's a lot of frauds out there.
There's still still kind of
operating fake black belts.
Fake gold medalists fake. Yeah. Why
would you want to be a vague black belt?
They don't know any better. They just,
they just been lying there whole life.
Mostly it's like the demons that you
experience when you do mushrooms.
They got their own demons and you know,
maybe it was childhood molestation does
people that lie that it's just nature.
That's just what they do.
They're probably beaten as kids.
Their parents were shit.
Everybody lied to them.
That lie that everybody that had
to be that person. Why does, why,
why can't it be the rich kid that's born
in Beverly Hills that has everything
and he lives, he's still
alive. He's still my kid.
He'd be a p this big of a piece
of shit is that. It could be,
but I bet a lot of those uh,
like real severe lighters,
they come from abuse cause they
have to like create a false life.
But you get a lot of abuse in rich
households too. Especially like,
even though maybe the dad has to work 16
hours a day as a bank or something like
that. He's never home. The mom's on
drugs. No one's taking care of the kids.
They're hanging around with a bunch of
other lost kids and their school and
they're all doing drugs
together and fucking off and
crime and all kinds of shit.
Just to be,
just to have an excitement in their life
because they're so bored and confused
and lost and lonely and they
start lying to a lot. I mean,
all comes from the same place. Whether
it comes from a rich kid or a poor kid,
it comes from your life being
fucked up and you, you're not,
you're not liking who
you are to eat mushrooms.
That'll help and deal with the demons
still with the demons and then go do
something. Go do something so
that you know that you could,
you could experience some nerves,
you know, and, and you could,
you could rise to the occasion, you know
what I mean? And learn about yourself.
That you could overcome that and you
could make mistakes and fail and then try
it again and succeed. And then what
the, the bad feelings that you get,
like when you're worried about losing,
you know, and these, these, these fears,
it's because winning is so high. Man.
I've seen you went so many times.
I've called so many of
your fights and you know,
I look right in your eyes whenever
you win. And there's just like,
this dude's on fire right now. He
was just like, there is no other,
I couldn't even explain to you
that feeling because no one can,
nobody can sign up to
do it other than fuck,
fuck yeah. Right. That's right. Yeah.
That's a feeling. You know what I mean?
Like that's, but it's, fuck
yeah. At times, like a million.
Ooh. You know, you know,
and, and God, it's, it's the highest
highs man. It's just insane how,
how cool it feels.
Um,
I've seen like with you
particularly like Kaos, right?
Like there's something about
chaos when you just crack someone,
then it's over and then you're, you're
walking around. I'm like, you'll,
you'll like glowing. Well, I feel like
I'm in my DMT. Yeah, you did it.
You went through all the fucking demons
and all the darkness and all the fear
and all the insecurity,
and then he landed and then it's over.
And then it's just as fast as it
started to tell her, that's crazy.
That's over. And then it's like,
hey, four weeks from now, blah, blah,
blah. Fell out. Yeah. What
are you going to do? Like,
we're going to fucking do it
again and to start over. Yeah,
we're going gonna start a lower and
if you realize that and like how,
how long are you gonna fight
til I'm going to find out.
I don't love it anymore Joe.
I really am man. That's,
I don't have an answer for anybody.
Like to go to answer the day
that I wake up and I'm like Nah,
what we need is medical science to catch
up where they get fixed everything 100%
right? Like head injuries and
bone injuries, everything.
Just put people in some sort of
microwave machine. Whether it is,
I bring it back to 100% thank you sir.
So then fighting becomes a matter of
temporary injury rather than permanent
injury and then it's a whole and
then it's a whole nother ball of wax.
It's a whole nother ball where
everyone's fighting 100% healthy. Yeah.
And you also don't have to worry
about like your longterm health,
which is like one of the big
problems with fighting. Yeah.
You're like you want to
arm bar me and break it.
Break to just see the guy
who got his motherfucking
arm crack the last fight. Um,
was it last Friday? Lincoln, Nebraska.
I didn't see it. Who got onboard?
A guy from Colorado and I watched
the crown was such a shit,
I don't know his name. He, um,
the Brazilian guy took him down arm
barred and snapped it home. Not In snap.
It popped it and pulled it all in, way
back and had it. Then he said, man,
I felt it pop, but I told myself winning
and losing this and he just kept,
kept on all the moments like that,
that you could just say a fucking
break it because I'm going to use the
microwave. Yeah. I'm going ride from
here, ambulance to the, to the microwave.
10 minutes. I'm fucking
him. Me, that's possible.
Someday maybe it's not in our lifetimes,
but it's possible someday and fighting
is going to be a different thing.
Like that was what was
so impressive about John.
When Victoria got his arm v toward Jesus,
he uh,
okay.
Oh man, this is nasty. This is right. Rate
Tabs. The tabs right here. But before?
Before, I don't know. I don't know
if they got out of the scene. Yeah.
Before this. There he is. He has,
he puts it behind his back
and he has it fucking boat.
This guy used to train at Jackson's
to the Brazilian guy on the bottom.
Hmm.
Yeah.
When John got tapped by v
toward that was so nasty.
I mean he was fully hyper extended and
it just didn't tie and his arm was fucked
up for a while afterward. Right. That's
why he had to host the ultimate fighter.
Correct. He really couldn't train
properly with it. Yeah. That's, that's uh,
it's going to be a different animal in
the future when people aren't worried as
much about permanent damage.
Right.
I hope I need it because I
do a lot of permanent damage.
Yeah.
The most damaged today's permanent damage.
Wild excursions.
I go on.
Tell me about the cave dive you want
to learn about cave diving. Kay.
So
first of all k dive in is the
last certification someone
we can get caving right
in, in, in diving. Like you
started off to get your open water,
then you move geared,
advanced open water,
get your ear nitrox and you start,
you start learning the rules of mother
nature because mother nature is never
going to take a loss.
She wins every time.
The only bitch I know that wins
100% of the time, right? You cannot,
you cannot fuck with her and
come out winning. So when she,
when she wants to take you, she takes
you. So you learn about all these
different rules of the water and of the
nitrogen levels that you're taking into
your body. Um, and the cave
diving is about five years.
And I,
I got my certification in high
school and I am a super cave diver.
Man. I love it. I love it. I love, I love
diving. I love everything about diving.
I love ship diving. Um, so no days,
caves, you name it. I love it.
So we were in Cozumel a
couple weeks ago and uh,
one of my old,
you could almost call him instructor.
He's taught me a lot of what
I know about diving today.
We a dove three or four days with some
buddies of mine that were down and goes,
Mel just went through, some ships,
went through, some k are, uh, like, um,
it's the coral reefs just playing around
down with them. And then we go and do a,
a, a serious diabetes. He's
getting a little bit older.
His mind is still very, very,
very sharp. But his motor skills
don't keep up with them much anymore.
Right. And in, in a cave diving, it, uh,
it's very necessity that you need.
So we jumped in this cave.
It's rewind to 20 minutes.
I had just kissed my girl and
my new baby and she's, I don't,
I don't really want you to
go like, right. I don't,
he just, I don't want to say his
name, but the guy you're going with,
like I'm worried. I said,
what are you worried about?
I said,
I'll come at home.
This is what I come home every time
coming home. Fuck. I Dunno. I Dunno.
So I pick up another, I order another
um, cylinder of air just for x.
Y I have to, originally I'm going
with order another cylinder air. Just,
I told her just for, just for,
just to fucking have it right.
No one's ever died because they
have too much hair. He gave diving,
you dive in third. So if we have
300 PSI would do a thousand Psi,
n would do a thousand psi out and we
have a thousand psi in case something
fucking happens
also in cage dive and they have lines.
You run these in a cave.
The law already had a line run.
A bunch of guys like me, tech divers
have gone into caves, discovered them,
they mapped them,
they named them and they put put lines
so you can follow them in case something
happens. Right. Get in and get out
lines and lines and none of the lines
really connect to for like the main lines,
we'll have like three
or four main lines down,
big channels of the cave
because caves are huge. Right?
From an intro to the main line. Usually
no one has a caveat. You have to,
you have to make it to
what's called a jump.
You have to make your own own line
because they just don't want someone
listening on deer today to go
find a cave, jump in, swim down,
and be able to get in and out
and get lost in there. Now also,
we have a Thailand incident.
We're looking at one in the city people.
So we make a jump tie off.
You put these direction arrows down.
Um, they're called cookies, right?
Pointing out towards the direction out
of the cave is that way if something
happens, you come out, when you
make a jump, you take your light,
you wrap it around your neck, and then
you have two hands that work on the line.
The Guy I was with didn't
follow some of our rules.
And in cave diving,
it's kind of an unwritten fact
that you only worry about you.
I'm coming home, right? I'm
fucking staying alive. So Joe,
you mean and I were Dave diamond,
if something were to happen,
I'm not going in there to get you.
No reason for two of us die
and only ones in there can die.
So he tries to tie off his buoyancy.
Fucking he hits the roof of the cave,
kicks his feet,
spins analysis on this line
that's supposed to be tied off,
which is our fucking lifeline
is now wrapped around him.
So I swim over to them and I tried to
help him unhooked this line and he goes
into panic and panic
kills everybody involved.
Everybody involved dies with panic and
that's something that I can't express
enough. So he started fucking
freaking out, hitting the roof,
spinning silk fucking hour.
And I just back out,
take about four or five
big strong steps back
when I grab a hold of the main line.
Now it's silting out now and
I see something silting out.
There's all this like sediment,
the ends on the bottom of,
of these caves and you were
like a little tiny room.
So if you kick your fin hard,
it kicks up like dark dust,
mud, sediment, silt. You can't
fucking see anything blacks out.
So I back out of the silt.
I grabbed the line and I see them in
their fucking freaking and panicking,
spinning and rolling around, getting all
caught up in this line. And I'm like,
fuck,
I just stay calm.
This was the exit. I know where it is
cause I know where I am. There's the exit.
He was making a jump to go down
another tunnel. There he is.
Now what I just tell you about the
rule that someone comes home, right?
I broke the rule and I went in to get him.
I said fuck it down.
So I let go of the line
and I go in to get him because his light
fucking is off now. And I'm thinking,
God damn, he spun up in this line.
Is Lights off? Did he drop his ray?
You later? Is he had air? Is he okay?
Sooner as I go into the sill,
fucking lose everything, man.
Lose my way. Where I am, my up, my down.
I don't know where I am.
A fucking panicky now I'm panicking.
Fucking freaking out more than
any I've ever breathing hard bang.
Hit My head on the fucking ceiling and I
just close my eyes. I'm like, God dammit.
Calla, calm the fuck down. Calm the
fuck down. Calm the fuck down. Breathe.
Yeah.
Came. See my hands in front of me. I
have two watches on their glowing right.
Those are my does let me know my death,
my time, everything. Or I have to, to,
to dive computers. I
check them. I look calm.
I checked my light, I gotta turn my
light and burn. Burn my, uh, our, um,
pressure gauges,
their glow in the dark rides.
I'm charged with my light and I look at
it. Okay. Air Check my second one. Okay.
Air. I know my third one's good because I
haven't even opened it yet. That's just,
just in case I breed down,
I fucking think.
And I came to see my hands in front of
me and to this day I closed my eyes and
it gives you nightmares. Write him out.
Just thinking about it. Cloudy, dark,
can't see anything.
All I can see is the home of my light.
So I turned my light off. Not trying to
think of like, all right, just, just,
just calm, calm yourself, figure this
out. Where's, where's our partner?
I started feeling around and he's nowhere
to be found, right? Nowhere to be found.
So I'm now,
I've calmed myself a little bit and I
start feeling the walls and I start moving
around.
I'm trying to think where am I?
But I don't know because we
haven't been down this channel yet,
so I don't visually haven't made
an imprint of, oh there's that.
There's this right.
Kind of like a mental imprint in my mind.
Cause that's what we're doing as
you coming in and landmarks. Right.
I don't have any of those. I don't
have any feel, I don't have any touch.
And I'm moving around,
moving around.
What took accomplish reading of the
direction of the front when we tied off of
the, at the first jump, right?
So I know 126 degrees is the way out,
but in a cave they twist and they move
and they're up and they're big and
they're deep and they're low ride.
They,
there's no rhyme or reason
how the water made the cave.
So it's kind of a
direction I can think of.
The first thing that comes to my mind,
I start swinging that way now.
I hit a wall, boom, and I go down.
I hit a wall and I'm fucking in panic
mode again. I fucking swim him now.
Just start swimming and
kicking a fucking going crazy.
I make my way out of the silt and I
fucking turned on back on the main line,
right?
I find the main line to the cave again,
which is 800 yards to the front,
to the door
and grab hold of the main line.
I fucking real it. Anyhow. Okay.
Now the entire behind me
deeper into the cave is free.
It's no problem. Silk Free.
I can see everything's good.
More I need to go is fucking
Celdt it out and blown.
Gone and completely fucking wash. I
can't, I couldn't see you sitting there,
but I can see everything behind us.
Sure.
We can't see you have the main line,
but I don't have the jump line to get
the fuck out. So I started thinking,
I was looking in the cave maps to try
and like before we went and just try to
get a visualize of, of, of the direction.
I'm trying to remember landmarks.
I can't see anything. I can't feel it.
I'm like, fuck, there was a split up here.
So I start, I, uh, go back into,
back into the silt again
and I start feeling around
and I'm feeling and I find a
hole and I'm like, is that the right
way? Is that the one I want to go down?
Where does that one go? Okay, maybe remind
me. And I remember, I remember that.
That's not okay.
Let's go to this next one.
I go into the next one and now this is,
this is where it's gotta be him going,
but all of a sudden I'm
swimming against the current.
And I remember when I came into this cave,
there's this very slow current,
which is why the entire case now
washed out from that point on, right?
The current is taking out. So I'm like,
fuck, you're swimming against the current,
so you're going the wrong way.
I somehow work that into my
fucking panic mind. We're,
we're swimming into the car,
we're swimming in the corner.
That's where we're going the wrong way.
So I fucking turned swim back.
I'm back on the fucking main line again.
Right? A find the main lines clear.
I out into the clear
main line. Fuck, fuck,
fuck. I start like hi preventing and,
and panicking. And I'm thinking, man,
are you fucking you piece of shit? This
is how he will die. What the fuck are you
right now?
And keep remind kissing my wife and kid
by kid saying I'm coming home today.
I'm coming home.
So I'd do it again and I fucking
venture into the fucking great unknown.
Fucking a bis. Total blackout,
another panic and other panic.
Fucking freak out.
Can't find a way he had chicken
losing air by the fucking second bro.
Cause now I'm breathing hard on breeding.
Fucking irrational and I'm sucking
my tank's dry. Right. Mind you,
I'm on air so I don't have, there's
no, there's no answer to this.
After I breathe my last breath,
keep checking anything.
Keep keeping my time look in direction.
Time, time, air, time, fuck, slowdown,
slowdown, slowdown, diamond pitch.
Fucking black. Can't see anything.
Trying to figure out where I'm at. What
I'm thinking. What am I doing? Okay,
we're running out of air. How much time
do we have? Kalbi we're at 28 feet.
I know we're at 28 feet.
I could probably read on this for about
another hour on this tag. Another hours.
We've got another hour. Okay. We've
been in here fucking 38 minutes already.
How are we going to do
start trying to find my way out.
I can't. Trying to find a way out.
I can't now. I started
thinking, what am I going to do?
I'm not going to drown Joe drownings
like my biggest fear of my life,
so everything that that's called
a BC and we carried on her bag.
It's a buoyancy control device.
That's how you,
that's how you control your buoyancy
when you're scuba diving, right.
It probably holds
20 big,
huge strong breasts, so I feel that
motherfucker up. This is my plane.
MOFILM IBC BC up,
which throws me to the top of the cave
bunk right now I'm only now I've got to
flip upside down and have like crawl on
the ceiling trying to figure out where
the fuck I am, how I'm at. Now I've
got to get out of a cave upside down
and I'm thinking, all right, we
switched to our last bit of air.
How are we going to do this,
Calvin? What are we going to do?
Filled RBC up when I run out of air,
I'm now thinking in my mind,
how am I going to die, Joe, right?
Tell my wife telling my kid I'm
not fucking. I'm coming home now.
I got to fucking realize
how am I going to die?
I have a notepad that you carry in
your pocket to draw and write on.
I'm thinking, what? What? What
are you going to say? What's your,
what's your letter going to be?
You're writing a fucking death later.
You're awake. You're a
fighter. We figured this out.
They will fucking find a way to quit.
You fucking bitch.
He's the conversation I'm having with
myself while I'm in fucking bleed.
Panic morning, complete darkness, thinking
that there's no, this is how people die.
What the fuck are you doing?
You're going to write a letter to
your fucking kid and tell her how you,
how you fucked up. I'm sorry.
Daddy's not coming home.
So I'm fucking thinking
I'm not going to drown.
I'm not going to breathe my last breath.
So I'm going to breed this BC that
just fill up with air and I'm a fucking
breathe it until the oxygen
level no longer happens and
I just pass out. That's,
that's my, that's what I've come
to realize how I'm going to die.
I'm going to fucking just
slip away and pass out,
keep breathing the same air until
I go away and I start thinking,
you fucking piece of shit.
You're,
you're giving up.
I think you're having legitimate
conversations with myself while fucking
complete panic. Like you're,
you're going to quit that.
You're writing a letter and you're gonna
fucking breathe your last air until you
pass out you fucking pussy. You're
a fighter. Figure the fuck out.
So I'm upside down and crawling on the
ceiling. And I remember when I came in,
we came in the big cave and as like a
huge fucking crack that runs along the top
turn.
Both my watch is off now at this point
because they're giving off light and I
kill my light and I said that crack
gonna fucking lead to the surface.
That cracks going to fucking give us
something. So I just call start panicking.
Me Panicking Lenia again because I'm
panicking. I don't know what to do.
I'm sucking air and I'm fucking breathing
hard and I'm hyperventilating and
crying on the sitting, crying on the
ceiling looking for this fucking cracking.
God Damn it.
I found it.
I found the crack and I followed the crack
and the crack got bigger and all of a
sudden I see fucking glow like green glow,
crawl and crawl.
Cron find it, try to get
up. I take her too big.
I can't fucking get out of the little
hole. Can't get out of the hole.
I'm fucking big, big,
big, big fucking hitting,
screaming, freaking out. Calm down. Kind
of like calm down. Kelly, this is the way,
calm the fuck down. Reel it in.
Reel it in. We're here. We made it.
Grab control,
follow the cracks and more
opens up out. Boom. There's
theK fucking I'm out made it.
You're coming home.
You're talking about. Wow.
That was the feeling.
Meanwhile, my guys out there,
I can't be mad at him because he panicked.
He grabbed line,
he fucking ran out the hole.
He looks at me and he says,
um,
okay,
so we're not diving together ever
again, Ali. I said, no, that was it.
That was it. And I texted my
girl, I love you baby. And uh,
they was fucking scary moment,
but daddy's coming home.
Okay.
And it was fucking so crazy
because that was, I mean,
I've almost died numerous times,
but almost dying slowly,
which puts it in perspective to me
like these guys on death row. What?
I always thought like, yeah, fucking
killer murder or man, that's fuck him
dude. Knowing the time and
how much time you have left,
that's some scary shit, Joe. Knowing
that you have two hours left,
how much air do you have left?
At the end. Maybe another hour,
probably an hour and some change.
But
could you imagine how I had to talk
to myself? How I was going to die?
Like to me that fuck me up.
I fuck me up really bad.
Like I probably had to go
do some mushrooms and asked
myself question questions
now because that fucked me up bad.
But the inner me, the fighter,
the youth do new fare at the fuck out.
But was I going to write a letter? I was
fucking damn close to write in a letter.
It was crazy, man. It was wild.
Damn. Hold on. I explained that.
Good for everybody who explained it.
I'm like a mother. Yeah, I'm nervous.
I'm like, I was there. Fuck Dude.
That is crazy. Yeah, man. And um,
I'm going to do it again now.
I'm not scared of it like that.
It's just needs to be done better.
I'll run my own motherfucking line. Well,
it also shows you how important it is.
Like what your wife was
saying. Yeah. Camp. She, you
know, she, she knew something.
She had a sense like right when people
fuck up a lot or when they're just that
person that just can't keep it together.
You gotta be real careful
around those people. Yeah. Yeah.
Fucking crazy shit man.
I mean that's what people kill
those people in war. Yeah.
You know, they just like,
look, we can't do this. Yeah, we can't.
Everybody killed. Yeah. Your, your,
your panic is sure. Yeah, sure.
Yeah. You're not hanging in there.
You, you become a detriment. Fuck Dude.
That is one of the craziest
stories I've ever heard in my life.
But I'm glad I got to share it
with you fucking press. Let's move.
I don't know how clean
can know. Agree Grandpa, that one man.
So as, um, as a tap out guys did for
me. I'm starting a new fight series,
cowboy fight series,
man,
amateur and we're traveling all around
the country and we're going to be putting
shows and I'm going to try and find these
new up and comer kids and bring them
the ranch. What are you doing it on?
I was talking with antler fight pass.
I think when we get on UFC
fight pass and um, yeah,
we're going to have probably
eight undercard fights,
probably two little guys in that area.
And then we're going to a four man
tournament for designed weight class.
We'll probably go,
I don't know,
maybe got a 70 or 85 maybe 55 first and
the winner of the four man tournament
gets to come live with me.
Train get brought up.
I know everybody, man. I can make a call
and get them on all the local promotions,
you know what I mean? Get them, build
these guys up and try and give back man.
And do like with the cow with the
tableau guys did for me and just really,
I don't know, show show.
Great idea. Do you,
do you think you're going to transition
into promoting or managing or anything
or training when you're done? I
want to do any training. No. No,
I don't think one of mine when
I around the corner in life,
I ain't looking back Joe, if I, you know,
I finally made the corner I looking back,
but I'll definitely help these dudes
out, man. I'll figure it out with him,
her or whatever it may be. You know,
I have no desire to train people.
People tell me I can teach very well.
I just don't agree. I don't know.
Maybe it'd be something that'd be more
interesting to you when you're not
competing. Right, exactly. You know, but
I'm hoping I'm moving into the movies.
I want to be a movie star. Yeah. Well
that sounds like fun. I just, uh, yeah,
I just did equalizer to Denzel Washington
was a lot of fun out of small part.
I am with the Dash brand x guys and
doing a lot of stunts and having fun with
that and I'm done. Zelle is great.
Yeah. Great Dude. Great
Dude. Never met him.
Yeah, he, uh, it was cool. It was super
cool to me. Super Nice. Um, this fun.
Someone welcome, you know,
I worked in Blue Jay Heran,
you know Jay these in that too. Yeah,
he's in that too as a cool, he's,
he fight Denzel's an Uber driver
in and uh, Jay fights him in a car.
It's pretty cool.
I'm trying to cells,
one of the greatest doctors and
several absolutely. I agree with you.
I understand you can go over like some
of the greatest actors that's ever lived.
You've got to have him on that list.
Like you got a chance to work with one
of the all time greats and he's so cool
as a Cadillac got there and he's just,
you know,
is it weird to be working with them?
It kind of was, but he was real.
I mean onset watching den Dell and then
Denzel on set is kind of different.
But he, um, you know, a
lot of the, there's Jay.
Oh man, that's cool.
Right? Um, it was fun man.
It was, it was such a learning
experience. But anyway,
I was here last week and I met
with Pete Berg who is a director.
He just did that mile 22
and I just got on a new Mark
Wahlberg movie, So I, uh,
got a small thing on that,
but um, he asked me to do
the fight choreograph for the
whole movie, so. Wow. Yeah.
Pumped on it, man. I'm excited
working, working, working
with the guys. Doing that.
So it should be fun to enjoy it. Love
it. It's cool. It's just another avenue.
Yeah, no, there's something fun to do
now. That'd be a good transition for you.
You know, so that's Kinda my plan.
Um, but last night over again,
game Baccarat,
I uh,
I'm going to be a new race
car driver or that happened.
My Buddy Ricky Stenhouse junior,
he has a dirt track race team.
So January, January, it's
called the Chili Bowl.
Chili Chili Bowl.
300 300 injuries.
And you take over five days you raised
and you work your way up to enter the
Saturday night, the Chili Bowl and
you, you, you get down there, there,
these are 400 horsepower cars,
you know, and error. Excuse me.
They weigh 400 pounds, man. I don't know
what it is. I don't, I can't doubt like,
I don't know. I don't know anything about
way more than 400 pounds right there.
400 horsepower. I, by the
way, 900 pounds. Really? Yeah.
And we've done dirt track.
That's insane.
Gives her a video of Chili
bowl for 400 horsepower.
900 pounds is insane. Yeah.
And they just shit and get
and so yeah, that's it.
Um, I'm going to January,
I'm going to the Chili Bowl and I'm
uh, I'm fucking going to give it. Hell.
Wow. How Fun. That sounds
like a good time. And I said,
so is there like a couple warmup days
or practice or, yeah, here it is.
Things look at this.
Whoa.
A dirt. Oh my God. That is insane. So
he's just going sideways everywhere.
Not just drinking. The whole thing
is like halfway drifting. Right?
It's just so all those people going
completely sideways around these corners.
That's hilarious. So in January, I,
Tulsa, Oklahoma. That's going to be me.
Wow. I can't wait. It's
gonna be so fun. Wow.
Those are good times. And I said, hey man,
I want to tell you just because of
my ego, right? That I'm a good racer,
but I don't really know if I am a
freshman race go carts. I have for you.
If you want to go down to the local
gold cart, chuck, we'll give it hell.
But I've ever done that. Never have so
excited you got to practice. I said,
I said like, is there some warmup or a
practice day? And they said, no, you just,
you can get a five laps before the
race. And I said, that's not enough. No,
no. You need a couple of hours,
hours, days, couple of weeks,
someone to show you like where,
where do you in the apex the term,
when do I jump on the gas?
So what,
so fast forward to January, Calvin's
going to have five labs to fucking get it.
And then I'm on, is there a place you
can go practice? I guess you can. Yeah,
I have to rent a track.
And I was at the monster thing last night,
so I was talking with all the,
all the right. And they're
like, no, we don't practice. We just
race. I think we just graced your rates.
There's no practice. And I was like, Huh,
you don't let you just race. Okay. Uh,
so can I pick up one of these car? Y'All
got a lot, like a loner I can get in.
And they're like, yeah, we
got you. And you show up. So
Chili bowl has got to like,
I guess there's 300
injuries is over five days.
You just get after it is Christ.
It was all excited. It seems like
that would be a skill though.
Like going sideways in the dirt like that.
You would have to learn how to scale that.
I don't have no,
they're gonna let you race with
pros. Yeah, that seems silly.
That seems like jumping into,
seems like it's going to Jackson right
off the street slapping on some Shin
Pads. It's exactly what the
fuck's happening. That is
so crazy. So yeah. Are you,
are you mother buggers and dose all
Oklahoma and January charitable cow is
coming in hot hot sun energy on me.
I get to pick a number.
I don't know what number to pick.
You get to pick a number and then you'd
pick a s a letters behind the number.
Wow.
I need to,
I need a good number followed by BMF
cause I definitely need that. Right.
What would be a good number for you?
I don't know.
Would it be the year of
your first pro fight?
Okay.
Would it be the year your grandparents
bought you the ranch? Who,
that's not a bad one. You
have to be weighed. What
year would that, what's here?
Is that I think 2011 11
BMF sounds pretty fun.
Learn DNF it. That sounds pretty
good. 11 BMF, that sounds pretty good,
right? Yeah. Fuck yeah.
I'm gonna send you videos.
You'll be able to play it and you're
like, man, that's not a bad one.
Love and BMF is good. Liam.
11 BMF. Hence it's the ranch.
Why not have it the birth date
of the ranch? Yes. Accurate.
You know, there it is. There it is.
Probably 311 on this mother fucker.
I'm putting in the wall coming sideways
around that corner and very little
control over the bed.
Almost no control.
And if you think you want to see me
down in the pits and come and take your
helmet off and get crazy, she just
going down. What other shitty you doing?
That's ridiculous. You probably shouldn't
be doing mounted, mounted, shooting.
I'm out shooting on a horse on a horse.
Do you put earmuffs on the horse? Yes,
of course. Really? Yeah. Stuff.
I'm down in her ears. Wow.
What kind of rifle? Shooting Colt
45 oh my God. That's hilarious.
Yeah.
So here's the rules.
You can't have more ammunition
than targets are on,
on the field, right? So
there's 10 targets targets.
So we load five shots in each six shooter.
Wow.
Right?
And you show your has to be a gun
exchange while riding full speed shooting
targets. So you, she one handed
while hold it on with the other hand.
Yeah, no, no, no. I'm a right handed.
So I run the range on my left
and I shoot with my right.
So here it is right here.
This is it.
So on hand is where you'd chew on hand
offhand is when you put it over over your
arm. So this is often cray, this some
cowboys and that's it right there.
Oh look at this. You run around and
shoot balloon. That is hilarious. Right?
These people in the stands,
it'll let you shoot the fucking
talking about people. That
data pull is not live.
And you mentioned you're just
shooting black blanks. Oh yeah.
So just the gunpowder
is burning the balloons.
Isn't that crazy that just the blanks
can do that much goddamn lunch.
There's a guy in Hollywood when I first
came here and like 94 who was on a set
and he didn't know that and he thought
it'd be funny to put a blanket up to his
head and shoot himself the head.
Yes. Some people shoot themselves,
shoot the horse.
I mean you shoot your horse doing and
he's probably not going to want to do it
anymore. What the fuck? Yeah,
they think that it's just a noise.
It's not just the noise. So learning,
learning and getting your horse training,
getting around gunfire and it's fun.
It's a good time.
That's practicing for
some old school revivals.
It's called SAS single action
shooting society. And uh,
once it was fights and during the
competitions and during the show is, it's,
it's like they,
they take it back and they,
everyone dresses up and that's hilarious.
Those are still to this day,
my all time favorite movies,
like the unforgiven,
C'mon westerns and some of the greatest
movies ever, ever. I'm with you.
I love him.
I love this stuff about them.
It's like that's a short period
of of a United States history.
But that's the period where people
were like, fuck it. Let's see,
let's see what goes on over here. Let's
see the cross, this divide a weak guy.
Yeah, he mega diddy.
That's one area. If I, if,
if there was a time machine that you
can go back and see what it was like,
if you could only go once and
stay there and that was it.
It was a one ticket ride. I ain't going,
no, no, it's the best time to live ever.
They would all want to come here. Of
course. Fuck. Would I go back with no Dui,
but you'd want to go to 3000
how do you know,
hold on.
So now you say that,
but now how did the guy in six 80
know that 2018 and these guys? Well,
they would have to know to know like
we know like if we went back to six 18
we're like listen,
what you'd go give them a little,
here's this is a laptop you opened up.
We have a thing called
Youtube and get on it.
And you just search and that's where
we live. So if you want to come there,
I'll trade ya. That. They would,
they would trade in a heartbeat.
But if you like wanted to go to the
future where everybody could read
everybody's minds and no one had Dixon
anymore because we all reproduced through
[inaudible],
it'd be over
orgasm button that's attached to this
helmet that you carry around with you
cause there's no more oxygen
on earth and everybody is
free. The new gas.
That's way better. Yeah,
I dunno man. I think right now it's
pretty fucking good. I'm happy with today.
I like it. So No, no
era you'd go to eh? No.
If I could come back, I'd go to like
1492 I think that'd be a good time.
So it'd be like when they landed Columbus
and I'd be fucking wicked pirate.
I think I'd make a good pirate. You
definitely make, do a lot of homos though.
Let's, no, no one mean they wasn't around
with that a lot. A lot of fires are gay.
I would be on a boat.
The ungay firing, hiring,
they're asleep. I mean, yeah, they'd
come me and I said, no, this is captain.
Don't play it at homie.
You're iPad should be sleeping.
Yeah. No, no, no, no, no. I would bring
the, I mean it makes sense, right?
With the scarfs and the crazy earrings,
they're all gay.
It makes sense in each other. That's
what they were doing, man. That's a fact.
I'm not making that up. Fair enough.
Yeah. I think I'd go back to the gut.
The Mongol days,
I looked to see gangs con.
I like to see just what that would look
like when they would take over a city
and kill a million people and rape
and pillage like yeah, insane.
They didn't have any respect for
anybody that didn't live in tents.
That's how gangster those people,
they're like, you live in a house,
you fucking bitch. They didn't even
treat you like you're a person.
I live in a tent with fire.
All they live felt tense everywhere.
This took them everywhere. Nomadic
people. So that would be your one stop.
I would like to see what that was
like. What did, what do you do?
Go back and then if you
died you'd come back here.
So that'd be like if you weren't going
to be a place where I sword. Yeah. Yeah.
There'll be a place where you can be
pretty assured that you're going to dog
gang. Is Open arms welcoming you into
the clan? If I came back with it,
why don't you be? Yeah, what
would you be hot for? Sure.
I got some shit to show for Zippo.
I'd have to tell him about Dan Carlin's
wrath of the con audio series for them.
You'd give a fuck so wrong.
You give him a phone where there'd be
no satellite tower. So it would be,
I would have to have some
recorded preloaded shit. Huh?
Some videos and movies and stuff.
And what would you,
where would you come in just in case
cause here or would you show up in like
2018 thermal optical lens?
Like you're like writing
riot police with low.
If I could bring anything I would
for sure be locked and loaded.
I want guns strapped to my hips.
Knives fucking fully.
If you show up with a gun to gang a con,
you now become games con
she hit right in the Dick.
All of a sudden you, he's not worth it
because you have fully automatic assault.
Write them on the roof.
Just started jacking that Predator style,
the new sheriff in town,
but for sure and then a movie like that.
Wasn't that John Claude van Damme
time cop? Yeah, I remember that Shit.
They went back in time and he
had a machine gun. Someone did.
They went back at Tom Fuck people
up and stole like civil war gold
over that.
But just like the movies say,
I think if you fucked that shit up,
you ruin everything you make it.
You might be in there just mowing people
down with machine gun and then you
would just vanish. Be Gone.
Mom. What do you manage though?
You'd have to write probably or
now that you're in this time,
uh, do you, are you no
longer in our time? Yeah.
The timeline changes the,
because you're there now and you see
this guy's got fucking machine guns.
Check this shit out.
This is a pretty easy way to make
money of this word from booster.
I'm from the future faggot there.
So that would be you.
Meaning gang has gone and would you learn
a little bit of his language you think
or you just try and go in
there with your iPhone and
the Internet? I think that the only way
you'd be able to communicate with them,
we would have to learn this language
for sure. That would be a little,
how hard would it be to learn?
Do they even know how to
say Mongo language anymore?
I don't think they even understand what
the, what the sounds were or think.
They're just guessing. I don't think they
eat on the side that go back grab one,
bring him here. Yeah. You'd have
to have them to home teach you.
I don't know if they know how
those people talk back then.
I think there's some real
speculation because you'd be
so smart and know so much,
but you couldn't communicate.
Yeah, there's no like,
it's not like going to Mexico now
where we kind of know a survey. So
yeah,
we'll like to think that's what the
same with the Mayans and that was only a
thousand years ago. We don't not, we
don't totally know how they were talking.
There's a lot of the expectation,
there's still translating a lot of those
ancient Mayan ruins and there's text
and Ken Kuhn, that's where it like
to loom. Yeah. When I went into,
I went to Chichen it too, which
is three miles there once. Fuck.
Did you take the tour? Yeah, yeah.
We had a professor take us on a tour,
so amazing ran.
They talk about
all the rituals and all the how they
drink out of the snow days and then they
tell me that how they'd cut their
testicles and I was like, wait, what?
And they're like, yeah, that's,
that's how the the the Sharman or the,
the grand master,
whatever the head religious guy,
I don't know what I'm an
idiot when it comes to that.
But they knew through their very smart,
right.
They knew of astrology and he knew
when he clips it in what we're coming.
So he would wait for the
eclipse that come. Knowing,
knowing that three minutes later and
it's going to just go ahead and pass.
But all the people that were with him
had no idea. They didn't know, right?
They had no idea that
it was going to stop.
They thought they had
done something wrong.
The gods are punished them with darkness.
So when the darkness comes, he like,
cuts himself in, offers his
blood to the, to the Gods,
moon, Sun comes back, all blood, Balboa,
Balboa got some precious
blood, precious blood. And,
and at that moment I was like,
so wait a minute,
you were just tricking these people.
I've been tricked my whole life.
I go to fucking church and I've
been tricked my entire life.
Like you just tell these people that
don't know enough and you knew the real,
but you told them it wasn't.
Wait a minute,
what's going on here? Hmm.
I sat back and thought,
and I was like,
so be it probably had to do what you gotta
do to control those people back then.
It's Goddamn savages. Yeah. Show him. Show
him a little ball. So what about today?
We've got it. We got to playing
fucking games. Yeah. Condo balls,
balls look up control on the sun back
covered it with the moon bitch and
everyone was like, oh my God, you brought
light back. Yeah. Otherwise no everything.
And you have a machine gun.
You got a machine gun to pitch.
But I only have three rounds.
So you couldn't,
you couldn't get up there and
really you going to really,
I mean unless you came armed up,
but how long would those bullets last?
Because there's no way you're
making a new bullet. Yeah,
everybody has to see it too,
cause they're not going to
believe you don't have to shoot.
Everybody wants you to feel me
being gone back to the Mayans.
What are the guns I'm playing with today?
Look like? Yeah, no kidding, right?
You fuck shit up.
Talk shut up for thousands of years.
That's the thing about guns though.
They get a little better over time,
but you didn't have a gun from 10 years
ago and it's state of the art, I believe.
I believe those guys 10 years ago,
hundred years ago are built
better than the shit ones today.
Then the shit ones. Yeah, but they still
make real good guns today too. Sure.
But that's the thing. The
thing is like, it's weird,
the technology of guns has sort of
in like, like you don't need it.
Like with Bose, one of the things
about compound bows is people,
a lot of people want to know the new
models every year because they get better.
Sure. But they don't really,
guns don't get that much better.
Like a gun from 10 years
ago is still a bad ass gun.
Like I have a bunch of Henry Rifles,
right.
The Henry rifle from nine from years,
it all American made from
years ago to the same gun.
They say now it's the same
gun. Yeah. Yeah. They nailed
it. Nailed. Got It. Got It.
Yeah. But it's, yeah. So I
wonder how much innovation is,
how much room for it until
we started doing laser shit.
Like different, you know,
I mean they got it. They
got to, they got to ramp.
It always drives me crazy about lasers,
like a star wars type shit.
How come I could see him?
Because there's clearly fogging around.
You didn't see him moving too slow.
Delights air, they hit. The bullets
are so much faster than lasers.
You see him to joke, joke, joke,
joke. Maybe it's that long of a shot.
Maybe their bullet is that
long. I think a late, oh,
LIGO flying lightsaber. Yeah.
Oh, I never thought about that.
We're sending big laser beam.
Right. Okay. Not other than that he hit
you, but it just keeps going. Right.
I didn't think about it that way.
Like you're shooting like,
like crossbow bolts of laser. Yes. Ooh.
Burning hot as a laser hot.
It's gotta be right as a cold.
There are cold lasers.
I had,
I had a bulging disc once
and I went to this therapist.
They put cold laser on it.
I Dunno,
but I liked this idea that she could
come back two more times this week and
we'll get you in. They just
kept doing it wasn't, yeah,
I don't think it really works,
but, but the cold bursts,
I think the laser person, if it was like
that, like flying lightsabers. Holy Shit.
Yeah, it's at the, I think the bolts were
just huge until you let off the trigger.
Still too slow.
See if you can find like a scene from
star wars one with the shooting at each
other. Those bitches, it's slower than an
arrow. Like they're not moving that fast.
Like if you try to watch an arrow coming
from a compound bow blogger to follow
so you couldn't catch it. Yeah,
no chance. No chance, no chance.
No 280 feet a second, no cheese
and catching shit. But that,
those, those bolts from those
laser guns look slower than that.
And you're probably right. You wouldn't,
the new, the new laser, you wouldn't,
there's no way you see it.
You wouldn't see shit.
That's just the magical for a
movies and you see it coming.
But it just makes me feel like they
think I'm an asshole. So when you,
when you take this time travel,
so if you could go forward or back,
you would go back 100% I would
too. Yeah, I would too. Well,
I'm a human. I don't think
there's a good future for humans.
I think we're going to be
something different. So you
think if you shoot forward,
you might be the only one in there.
Yeah, there might be no more people.
Everybody's an engineer in a cage
getting probed. Oh, for sure.
They're going to test you.
I can't believe we found one of these.
It's like a Tasmanian Tiger or something
like that. Like holy fuck. Lock it up.
Look at
the video of the last Tasmanian Tiger.
Jamie. See if you can find a video of
the last Tasmanian Tiger died in a zoo.
I want to say in like 1930.
What's interesting is they
think they're still alive,
but Australia is so big. Australia is as
big as the United States. There it is.
That's a Tasmanian tiger.
That was the last bus drives.
It's a Marsupial Predator.
It's the last um,
like real mammal Predator or Marsupial
Predator that lived in Australia.
That's what it was like. It
was like a crazy dog looking
thing. But they've found,
look at that,
the mouth open picture of it.
Look at that fucking mouth on that thing.
That is crazy.
But there are people that
are real reasonable people
that believe that there's
still a few of those
that exist in the wild.
It's been enough sightings of these
things that they think that, uh,
what is the actual name of that thing?
It's got a crazy name.
Cicilline right. How does it spell t,
h y, c e. L. I. N. A.
Thylacine, whatever it is.
That would be us being one of those
fucking cage is the last person just
wandering around, looking around
stupid. All the robots are all,
so if you could bring one person,
hmm,
would you bring a best friend or
would you bring a female counter?
You've got to bring a check, bro. Goddie
right. You got it. Yeah. Yeah. You got it.
I'm with Ya. Because you wanna bring
your friend like drought. Look, I love,
I love to hang out with you,
but you know,
I don't want to be the last guy in
a cane in China without some pussy.
No, no, no. Yeah, that would be, yeah,
but if I was a pirate then, you
know, I guess it wouldn't be okay.
What was the gay cowboy movie? What
was that movie? Brokeback yeah,
we ain't going there. And how we ain't
going, man, we are not going there.
A little too intense for this
fierce that shall not be conquered.
No disrespect to the gay friends out
there listening. Cheers to you. Hey,
cheers to you. Hmm. Mm.
I would definitely go in the past just
to see what it was like an ancient Egypt
or ancient Rome. I mean, uh,
I just got back from Italy and we were,
uh, we checked out Pompei of course,
you know,
and you wandering around where all
these people died almost instantly from
volcanic ash 20 feet
high and you see other,
you saw it right away and you can see the,
there's one where they found recently
where a dude got hit in the head by a
flying boulder.
He just see his skeleton and a
giant rock where his head would be.
It's a way to go. Yeah. I mean
I got nothing though. Boom.
Done blackness,
DMT world DMTs out where we go.
You think maybe there is,
look at that and that's why you
seeing not kinda got him. Oh God.
At that look at the article
cause it says Fuck Paul pay,
but fuck this man in particular, man. God
was blowing from the mountain.
Yup.
Big Chunks of rock that gets
spewed out of this volcano. Wow.
Yeah. The whole thing's
crazy. Like when you're,
when you're wandering around Pompei and
just realize that each face forward you
got hit in a mug. Right? Like
he saw it. Ah, right. Yeah.
He got, yeah, it's true. I didn't even
write that. He didn't, he wasn't running.
Oh look at that one man.
That was fucked.
Is that just volcanic ash modification
just preserved with volcanic ash.
Look at its teeth. That is
sane and if spooky, I'm dead.
This, this guy is coming
on my next trip for sure.
Show up.
Just show up.
Fuck. That is the way
to go. Fall. Kainos men.
I have a friend who goes to the big
island every year for Thanksgiving and I'm
like, you going back? He's
like, fuck yeah. I'm like,
you're crazy. You're going by.
That thing's on fire.
I would have it splits in half and
sprays out like it's, it's taken over.
Then the gods we've made the gods mad.
Palae was pissed.
What? What area did you do? Do
you think you go to the wild west?
Where do you think you would go? Oh,
I was, I around it towards pirates,
but then you surely whip shot me
back. So yeah, we'd probably be,
how about Lewis and Clark? If you could
go on a Lewis and Clark expedition,
how wow would that be?
Make your way across the unknown.
No one knew what the fuck. What
the fuck? Just taking a chance.
Try to walk across the United
States. I mean that's, that's,
that's almost as you're saying,
the same era.
I wanted to go and Columbus just
trying to like, you know what?
Let's just say Lacrosse is flat.
Earth. Yeah. Yeah. Now it wasn't flat.
Now we're back to flat.
Some people we discovered it wasn't flat
and now we're back to flat and I have
value and people want you to while
doing the pilot school that I'm in.
Like you have to keep adjusting for
the curvature of the earth. No, no,
no. It's not real. It's not real. The
world's flat. It's flat. I like that TV.
It's just a lack of education.
It's,
it's an interesting thing too because
it shows you how distracted people are,
but that they want to argue about
something that's already been figured out.
Videos and the literature that
people come up with for these insane,
I can you Google earth
you want by the time,
by the time it's done,
you're like,
God damn.
It might be flat
and they're going to put this in the
video. Cowboy realizes the earth is flat.
He had a lot of good points there.
Yeah.
He's not sitting across from Neil degrasse
Tyson because if he was Neil degrasse
Tyson, but like hold on, hold on. That's
not how it works. Hold on. That's wrong.
Hold on. This is why we know that's
incorrect. See, I don't have,
I don't have the knowledge
to be able to check,
constantly readjust for
the curvature of the earth.
I know that one fact and then and then
the rest of them they're like, and then,
and then I'm like the crazy
ones. The water. Yeah.
Water. Water doesn't stay
on a curve. Yes. Does does.
Yes it does. It does. Gravity.
It's called the oceans
and if gravity's not real,
where the fuck do you think waves come
from bitch there and what did they say?
There's a glacier all
around. Holding? Yes. Yeah,
the 700 foot walls,
an ice wall around the outside edge and
then the government protects the ice
wall when you see it. Why? Why would
they? Why? Okay. This is just me.
I'm nobody.
I'm just Joe blow reading an article.
Why would NASA and the government's
been millions, billions. Trillions,
right? To protect the fact
that it's around earth.
When it's flat to me, I would say, oh,
we live on a flat earth.
This is where it gets even stupider
because how would it affect my day to day?
They're trying to protect us from the
truth or shield the truth from us that we
live in an incredible special environment.
We live in the firmament
that's protected by a dome.
The creator is real and that all the
elite powers want to keep this information
from you. It's basically people that don't
have an education, that are failures,
that use all their energy misplaced to
make these videos that don't make any
sense. They've figured
it out, they make sense.
They make sense to me on
the dummy that watch it.
Like because anyone making a video
where no one's interrupting you,
no one's telling you you're incorrect,
you're allowed to just continue to watch
bullshit things over and over and over
again unchecked.
And so if you listen to this and they
use big words and it sounds smooth,
they have for, they have, you know,
your drawing is behind them and charts.
And I'm like, clearly that picture shows,
I definitely don't have degrees there.
Ain't nobody with a degree out there
that's telling you there's a nice wall.
I don't know man. You can get some
pretty shiny degrees lately. Well,
there was an article recently about
schizophrenia and I think anybody that
thinks is really the ice
wall and they have a degree,
they should probably go to a doctor.
They're probably on some sort of
medication and something's wrong.
There's some sort of a de levels are off.
There's really think there's
an ice wall around a plate.
The earth shaped like a plate.
So are they just pumping?
They're just pumping oxygen in or our
natural habitat creates it and they
believe that, uh, that's a good
question. They don't believe in gravity.
So I don't know what they believe in.
They think that I've ever,
what happens when you're sending rockets?
It hits the dose or I'll fake bro
rockets or fake satellites and fake,
you know what else is fake dinosaurs?
They don't believe in dinosaurs.
But you want to know, show
me Jamie. We just fake to,
we just saw the mummy from
the fuck Kanick. Yeah, right.
And she fake. He's real. It might be
fake. Looked at a picture on Google.
We really [inaudible] he's real.
The dude who got hit in the head
with a rock is real as real as fuck.
So the dinosaur that he got hit by a rock,
he's fake.
It could be, I wasn't there 65
million years ago is a long time.
Yeah.
Especially with the only 6,000 years old.
They have one thing on their side and
this is the one thing that they are on
their side. This is one of the
reasons why they make this argument.
It's because when dinosaur
bones were first discovered,
when they were first discovered,
there was a whole race to find dinosaur
bones and there was a lot of fuckery.
There was a bunch of people that were
faking things and piecing things together.
It didn't work and hiding bones
and saying they found them.
They were just trying to
make a name for themselves,
but that's just greedy human nature in
the face of an actual real discovery.
That's very valuable.
That discovery was that they're dinosaurs,
that there was a gigantic breed of lizards
that Rome has millions of years ago.
Yeah.
And so all that's just propaganda.
So you're saying in in Colorado on
the side of the mountain by red rocks,
they have a whole closed off section
where they're just doing masturbations.
Yeah, Andy's a huge giant
feet print in that. Yeah.
In the rock that you can go
up and touch a different,
probably four or five different
species of Badass lizards.
My friend John,
he's,
he knows a dude who owns a
ranch in Montana and they
found a t rex on this guy's
ranch. They pull the t rex
out of this guy's ranch.
They found it in the ground and they
gave him a fuck load of money for it.
I was like, if they find some
sort of discovery like that,
that's worth $1 million. Has to be.
Yeah. It has to put that's fake. No,
it's real as fuck.
That's what I'm saying.
They found this one thing that was
poking up and he brought in these geology
archaeologist. What? What would they be?
All but it took you tell him you wouldn't
have a t rex to hang on and keep one,
two, one. Two is a person who
searches for dinosaur bones.
Like you have a bear tooth hanging.
I have a fucking t.
Rex tooth is an archaeologist.
Right.
I was thinking to archaeology being
human history. No archeology is what?
Your wife Paleontology.
That's what they do because
they're always digging up old shit.
Oh, that's so true. So true.
True. They come at you, his ship
get her a web.
Oh yeah.
Paleontologist.
Yeah.
So they called it a paleontologist
paleontologist start cleaning off whatever
this was, and then he's
like, holy fuck. He's like,
this is a Goddamn t rex. Apparently.
It's like, Oh, a lot of it, you know,
sometimes it's like you only
found a couple of phones. Yeah,
they found a lot of shit.
So I would like to see that man,
if I could go back when I'm drastic parks.
So now
I'd like to see that too. Now we're
going all the way back. Yeah, that's,
that's Colorado right there.
That is fucking insane. Insane.
So what the fuck? That is insane. Yeah.
Do you know how much time that
would take to, to falsify that?
They going out with dessert.
Here's,
so you've got to brainwash
five people and tell them more.
Warren and do is wrangle chip this rock
out because we've got to fucking fake a
bunch of people. Have you seen this
in person? Yeah, I've been there.
Walked all that. You crawl over it? You
just like walk on, walk on, walk on it.
Well she a little gate right there
if you back out a little bit. Yeah,
a little gate, but that's just a
little gate. There it is right there.
The little girl.
That's crazy man.
I mean that's right there in Colorado.
Wow. Right by red rock. Yeah,
exactly. It's right there. It's hard
to book a Gig and red rocks, man.
They're booked up til like 2021 22
you can do a live show in red rock.
Fucking epic. I was
trying, but I can only get
like Tuesday nights and Wednesday nights
up until I know what? Tuesday night,
Tuesday night is better than
never. Never. No night. Yeah.
Fucking so I'm going to
need a couple of tickets.
So the people don't believe the earth is
the believe the earth is flat and I'll
round.
They don't believe in dinosaurs.
They don't believe in nuclear weapons
either. Wow. That's the other one.
Nuclear weapons are a hoax hoax.
Yeah.
Only a few people don't
believe Australia is a hoax.
And a lot of people say that's
disinflation and discredit
plane fly upside down and shit.
And that's all upside down.
And that's where the
Australians coming from.
Cause Kyle notes in Australia right
now. I could probably call him. Um,
he's probably a government agent bro.
Shit,
any phone call you make to him was
just going straight to the Illuminati.
Kyle. Yeah Bro. Yeah. You
gotta be real careful.
What does he do? Is he
retired now? He's coming back.
He's trying to come back really well
the problem is he didn't fight. He,
his UFC career out, uh, when he retired.
So we'll still have them under
contract under the contract.
How many more fights don't,
didn't get into that.
So you wanted to retire
and fight somewhere else?
I think he just wanted to retire,
but now he's got the itch again cause
each comes, she's like, yeah, fuck it.
I'll come back to maybe
whatever. And they're like, no,
you come back with us
or are you going to come back at all?
Gotcha.
Contact legal agreements.
Tricky world we live in and I figure if
he was a government agent he could just
sweep that under the rug.
Right.
You have a tendency to
obvious as far as the cover,
part of the cover is you get
a blocked in the contract.
So he's becomes one of the regular
working man. He is a working man.
I can say to you, damn standing dot
goddamn contract and you're like,
you're one of us Kyle.
Meanwhile he's wearing a wire.
Damn Damn.
Yukon is the worth flat Kyle.
It's definitely not to say water world.
Antidoping agency
wallet. Let's watch her.
The water's upside down.
My mom. Yeah. Yeah.
There are a different breed of
human over there. They just,
they evolved for hunting because
they're prisoners. We just,
what a great idea. Bring them to the
best place on earth and drop them.
But the stupid, yes. Wait,
I don't have the, I'm not getting the
debt. Oh, you're just dropped me on.
It's super bad ass island.
That's bigger than the one you're on.
Bigger than when you were on way better
weather. Way better weather. Gorgeous.
And then they dropped all these
prisoners off and they started like crazy
hierarchy. And the ones that didn't really
make it just went into the bush. Yeah,
they're still there today.
And then there's the aborigines who
were already there and then on top of
that hot chicks,
I don't know what they did to grow
them hot out there in Australia.
Something about the,
the prisoner genes,
the wild prisoner genetics,
some about that wild
fucking criminal gene.
While criminal dreams are are the,
are the crazy alpha male guys,
the guys that are there like
the weaker 2018 liberals
are saying, whoa, no,
you can't do that. Yeah.
Was a lot of that troll going on to the,
can't do that.
So you're going to Australia? Yeah.
Use the word faggot users faggot. Damn.
That's one of the last words
I got in trouble with EOC for saying
faggot. I'm not allowed to say it anymore.
Well you already just did. I know you're
just making the noise. Yeah, this is,
this is like a, this is like a
shell. We're in a bubble. Okay.
So did they,
it's Vegas.
I'm drinking all night and they had
me do this show at 8:00 AM on a Sunday
morning to reflect the fight.
It was me and I'm a cm punk and I'm
reflecting the fight that DC had with
Anderson Silva, who I respect.
Appreciate. Great Dude.
I didn't like the way DC fought that
fight. So when somebody asks you about it,
I said if anyone out there like a
fucking faggot and held him, you know,
he didn't fight to win. Right. Well
that was completely out of context.
I didn't mean that. Like, I didn't
mean like he was a homosexual.
I just say faggot like,
like you're a bitch and you're a punctual.
I have to explain myself.
UFC makes me put on this a rainbow shirt
and tell them I have problem with jumbo
shirt. Rainbow. Oh, rainbow. They
made you put on a rainbow shirt. Oh,
share the PR team and, and,
and apologize. And you know,
because I have him as homophobic in
and of itself, I have all the, all the,
the gay activist rights coming after me.
Now they're wanting money.
How strange is that? They want money
from me because I offended on it.
I should donate. I did have to
do any, I did donate. So anyways,
I tried to get on it and explain Muslim.
I said, man, I didn't call him a Faggot,
like a faggot. I called him a
faggot bitch. And that backfired.
Big Time. Yeah. And I, I
mean that's just how I talk.
I if I called you a punk bitch Faggot,
that's just, that's just what I said.
I don't mean it in any
other way other than that.
But the thing is, here's the thing, right?
And I don't mean it homophobia.
Homophobia is bad. Right? But our words,
our words bad.
Like what if you feel the same way?
Like is it a real issue is in I have to
pee so bad. Good, good. Pete. All right,
you gotta pick your beer?
Yeah, I'm three and good luck.
Okay.
I think all words are dependent
upon the context and your intent.
Like what do you, what do you mean have
you say to someone like, come on bitch,
like in there, your friend that
it's fun. But if you say to someone,
come on bitch,
and then you hate them.
Those exact same words or taking
on a totally different meaning.
And that's the same thing with every
word except the n word, the n word.
It's like it's so toxic.
You can't even use it joking around and
you definitely can't use it the way you
could say almost any other word.
So like,
yeah,
well I had a bit that I was trying out
for a while but I had a abandoned it.
Where else like the n word is one word
that you can't even call yourself.
Like you, you can't even
say God, I'm such an n word
because faithful get fucking mad at you.
You can't even say it. But if you're,
but here's the catch.
If you're a black guy you could toss
that shit around like a beach ball at a
concert and it's fine.
Okay.
If you're a black girl
you could use it as well.
Although a little more sparingly please
grace.
They can't use it the same amount.
Black girls like tend to use it just a
little bit more leniently but they could
do whatever they want with that word.
It's one of the more fascinating words I
think in human history in terms of like
its its impact. What it means
and how it can ruin your career.
Like didn't that one congressman
have to resign because
Sasha Baron Cohen had him
yelling out the n word. Right.
What was he was just because of that,
but that probably it was on the list
of things. What was he, what did he do?
Was he a representative George and maybe
this bigger future. What is up open?
That commode you got in there I think
does everything does everything.
She taught water up your asshole.
Ooh Wee. It's warm when you sit down.
It was wonderful. He did. Yeah.
You would fit in great with
the pirates if you said guys,
just trying to complain,
Bro. Come try my commode out.
It gives a little hotter shall walk.
You're not homophobic guy. No you're not.
But it's, it's one of those
things where if you say it,
I guess if you're a gay person and you
hear someone say you'd be really upset,
like they are being homophobic.
The problem is like the, we had,
this bitch is not good enough.
No certain situ and they're trying
to get that one to remember.
W W Kamau bell wouldn't say, he says
he doesn't say bitch anymore. I'm like,
all right dude, you're self
censoring or limiting language.
I did this podcast with wolf man serious,
and he tells me that he now
not a homophobic at all.
I just caught me off guard. I didn't
know, I didn't know how to take it.
When he told me that he
experiments,
he didn't kind of know if he like boys or
girls. And I was like, oh, Jason Ellis.
Yeah. Oh, okay. Yeah.
And I was like, what?
You don't know what you like, here's
the guy had been to a couple parties,
you know?
And
I just go both ways and we just have
groups of people and sometimes it'd be
groups of guys. And I was just
scratching my head and like,
Huh,
ah, okay. I didn't know how to, I didn't
know how to, how to take that out. Right.
If you don't expect it. And
I've known him for years, years.
They dropped this ball on
me and I was like, man,
uh, I don't, I didn't know how to take
it. It was just, it caught me off guard.
It was weird. He's like, what
do you think? You think? I
like girls, but I also like,
or I thought,
I liked guys
what I wanted to say. And what I say are
two different things. You know? It's like,
what'd you want to say? I want him
to say, man, um, no offense, but man,
you put a dick in your mouth
and you are a Faggot, but this,
so now you changed.
No,
I understand that you've wanted to say
that you wanted is that the inner me was
wanting to say and I just
looked at him like, fuck,
I didn't what?
I was just so blown back by it.
But why is that shocking if
people are definitely gay,
it's not shocking because you
didn't expect, I didn't expect it,
but it's not shocking that someone's gay.
It's like there's a lot of gay people,
right? Nothing wrong with it.
I don't care at all, nor do I,
but when you don't expect someone to
be gay and then you're like, whoa,
because then you thought that he was like,
you look like you and I were just a
couple of straight guys hanging out for
meanwhile. He, meanwhile,
he was not. He is, uh,
the one thing that is odd with me,
with people that say things like
that is that they go sometimes.
Sometimes I like guys and sometimes I
like girls. Like I couldn't imagine.
What would that, that would be like
or you're not sure? You're not sure.
So me like, what do you mean you don't
talk straight sometimes you not like Joe,
no matter what. Every time I go
to basket robins, I get vanilla.
That's what I'm going to work with
strawberry, you know, like rocky road.
Sometimes I'll, I'll, I'll dabble in
there, but if you brought me back vanilla,
you know, I'm gonna like
that, you know? It's not like,
well, as long as I go there.
Right. I mean, there's people that do
look, they're just wired different.
There's nothing wrong with it.
As long as he's not trying to fuck you,
but why would that be a problem?
All of a sudden will be a problem
if you don't want to fuck him. True.
[inaudible] it makes you realize what
it's like to be a girl in the most
insignificant ways.
Cause with the girls,
obviously most more dangerous because
guys are bigger than you and you're going
to actually hold you down and fuck you.
But when, when you're around gay guys,
I used to work out at a gay gym
when I was doing news radio, right?
I worked at Gold's gym and
Cole and I used to describe it.
I was a tasty little morsel
in a big gay stu just,
it was the closest gym to the studio,
so great gem,
but it was filled with aggressive
gay guys that had like those.
They had those scrunchy socks,
like fucking,
they were in a music video from the
1980s like their flashdance socks.
These guys like timberlands and style,
like Super Tan and Roy it up and just
hit nine each other left and right.
Leather vests on us.
I mean it was crazy.
It was such a crazy scene
and when you go there,
you realize that these guys are,
they're like leering at you.
They're not looking at you like a guy
going, what's up man? How are you doing?
You know, use the triceps, you know? No,
it wasn't that they would be looking
at you if you walked into an all female
lesbian super smoke show Jim.
That's how you'd be looking.
All of them. I go, Oh yeah,
but I cas have you want me to you all
all lesbian fee because all lesbian Jim,
they probably looked like Tom
Arnold and my fantasy that I'm in,
they're hall like super high fitness
models. I get in there working out,
hitting each other. If they were
legit lesbians, they'd be like,
what the fuck are you looking at?
That'd be the same.
Then you would be the perpetrator.
It you'd be feeling like the
guys look at you and you're like,
what the fuck you looking at?
Yeah. I mean, the real thing is I,
I feel like, uh, gay and straight people,
everybody can get along fine as
long as everyone's on the same page.
And as long as they're
not trying to fuck you,
if you don't want it and you're not
trying to fuck them if they don't want it.
Like if you're not trying to fuck these
lesbians cause you, you, you, you respect.
In fact,
they only like girls.
That's all great and the gay
guys aren't trying to fuck you,
but can we get tell by looking at someone,
can we get mad at the double standard?
You're saying, Hey, these
gay guys, they say sometimes,
what about these girls that are like,
well,
I sometimes like girls and sometimes
I like guys and girls and then you're
listening. I'm like, yeah, that
sounds like a pretty good idea.
It does sound a good idea and I think
we should shut the fuck up about that.
Otherwise they're going to get insecure
or they've got to stop that practice,
let them keep going and have a good time.
But all of a sudden the guy's like, God,
that's not like girls. Hey Joe, you
want to come on the guide shipping?
We're hypocrites. Hypocrites. Yeah.
But there's something about
God for straight guys.
The idea of a guy fucking you or making
you suck his dick is the most horrific
thing.
It'd be relaxed to the cave
diving experience for me
that the nightmares would be,
but
I have no zero ill will towards them.
And I don't have any problem with them
in any way in society, in any way,
shape or form. I'm not even remotely
homophobic gay people. Sure.
But there's a reality that gay dudes are
dudes and dudes are kind of gross and
they will try to fuck you.
You know?
And that's the one thing I had a
friend of mine who was a, he was a,
a wardrobe guy and he was a gay guy.
And he was always telling me about
these straight dudes that he would, uh,
he would lord the man and turn them and
get them suck. His Dick was hilarious.
He goes, tell stories about
that. About about college,
how the gay guys would
fuck the football players.
And I'm like, wait, the big bad football
college guys who are getting what?
Yeah, he didn't. Same. Same thing you'd
say that's theirs. Theirs, they love it.
They love the term. Like just like a
guy would love to turn a lesbian club.
That'd be a mission when it, yeah,
I used to have a joke about that,
that guys believe in gay guys.
Like I believe in gay guys,
but I don't really believe in lesbians.
I think they think they're lesbians
cause that's just cause they ain't got to
hold it this way. They got me, I turn,
every guy looks at a lesbian like,
hey, I know she thinks she's a lesbian.
Let me fuck her a couple of times.
It'd be nice to her. We're like,
I can eat pussy way better than
another girl. I don't know Torrance.
She's no way.
And I brought the Dick but
not,
not only nice fuzzy
and I brought the dam. The data. Yeah.
So men don't necessarily
totally believe in lesbian.
I don't. They 100% believe
in gay dudes. Then why?
Why don't butch girls act more like soup?
I mean they do.
They cut their hair and they were,
some of them do,
but the gay guys all got
the snap and depressed.
There's some fucking like
beefy bodybuilder gay dudes
that look like straight
guys. Yeah. You can't tell. Yeah. Do
they slap your ass in the gym? Take good.
Whoa. No, I want to get a beer after
you stop right there.
It's like you should be a way to tell
like they have different markets,
you know shit kinds of birds. Like
oh that's a female. It's a female.
Birds see those extra feathers.
But what if it's a transgender?
Now what if it's wearing female feathers?
But who? That's an odd one, right?
Because that's one that like
we didn't have children.
So how do you feel about if you're
little girl has to go to the bathroom but
there's a guy girl in there?
Well like what draws the line?
I would hope that either way,
like if you are a son is
going to the bathroom,
there's some pedophile child molester
that preys on boys and he asked me a guy
and he's in that bathroom.
It has nothing to do with your,
your sexual orientation has to do with
you being a Predator and a piece of shit.
But that could happen for straight people
just as easily as it happened for gay
people. Diseases happen
for Trans People. It's,
it's someone who's willing to pray on
smaller people that are vulnerable.
I was just,
I wasn't even going to pedal.
Like there's a lot of like trans people
that would be more than happy to be
really friendly to your daughter
and it would be an issue at all.
She pulls out a wiener and peas and you're
doing a show and your daughter's like,
and your daughter's like,
what the Hell, dad? Um,
right. But what if you had a girl who
became a transgender girl? She's big tits,
but she wanted to keep her dick.
Yeah. And where, where she go.
She's wearing a skirt, high
heels right now. Today. Where
should go? Which bathroom?
Shoes. I don't know. I want to
say, I want to say she's got,
she's got the equipment right. She's
got the equipment and full equipment.
Full equipment for, for the male female,
but just tits, like his bro example,
go to bally Jay's Twitter page.
I'm just saying that, that, I think that
would worry. She feels like a woman.
But she was born a man. Dick. Yeah, but
she has a dick, but she's as Co Bailey.
Jay's my favorite example.
I hope she doesn't mind me using her
because she's a transgender girl.
That I like is as much a girl as you
could possibly get while still having a
dick. Like see, look at that set. Right.
That confused the fuck out
of here. Right? Like, Hey,
what's going on here now go to the
media or media page. They kill her now.
She's alive. No. Did they,
do they like Jonah? I mean,
she says she pulls her out. This is
the thing. She's got a giant Dick.
So she's got these big tests and
then hey, there you go. Oh Man. Yeah.
So where does she paying,
you know I'm,
I'm cool with her going to
the girls' room and what?
I mean just she's going to probably squat.
It's not like she's going to
stand there with their pants down.
Just hosing the wall.
Letting everybody know you feel,
I mean if she went into the men's room,
that would cause more of a conflict. Yeah.
Could you imagine,
could you imagine something like that?
Do you're saying let her
go into the female? Yeah.
Not just for safety, but just like
who she identifies with. Look,
it's a weird thing, right?
Because the Trans Person Is,
do you go into the family room?
Do you go into family bathroom in between?
That's probably the, that's
the safe bet. Ironic.
She's anti if she's not going to make
a family with what there's going on,
that's so confusing. That is so how
does that kind of pregnant? Yeah.
I mean not yet,
but to maybe in our
machines you can also
change agenda Changer.
That would be a way where transgender
people would probably be the most happy,
where they didn't have to like hormonally
become a woman and through surgery and
throw it, but instead they just
actually turn you into a woman. Bam.
My time. You done. Oh, you want to be
a girl being and maybe go back. Well,
if that's the case, yeah,
you could go there and back.
Where do I sign up and Zach, because I'm
going, I'm going to go check this out.
See what it's like for a couple
of days a week. Go to Vegas,
let a couple of dudes banging. Yeah.
Now for dot. Now that's another one.
That's weird. Now. It's
weird. It's weird again,
because you have that memory when you back
and tell my friends like, dude, I
want to bang. They got still out.
It's always in the back of
your throat. Yeah. So yeah.
Yeah. That would have to be a
giant issue.
So yeah.
You say you would try it,
but then you had to have the
memory of trying it. Yeah.
You'd have to in the middle, you could
maybe pass that you were a girl. Maybe,
but one of the guys trying to fuck,
you'd be like, Hey, no dude, no, no.
But he's like,
but you're a girl.
Would you do a random or would you think
you'd do a friend of yours that you'd
like? Would you give any Bravo,
Bravo. I heard some shit.
Let's go.
Not only would I do a rant about where
a mask like fucking eyes wide shut,
but that's the,
when you as a girl,
you wouldn't look like you
as a girl when you hotter,
hotter to give out of curly hair.
He had his god damn.
Imagine if you zapped over to the
female and you were just precious,
are you? They're like,
oh, you problem a problem.
A real problem.
Yeah. Fuck yeah. So they made
you wear a rainbow shirt,
isn't it? They sold it to about how gay
people took over the rainbow. I'm like,
it's, there is a rainbow. It used to
be in leprechauns pots of gold. Nope,
not anymore. Not Anymore. They took
that shit over. They own, I don't,
I don't fully understand. I'm sure
someone will comment on your youtube page,
youtube page here and tell
you why that uh, why, why,
why the rainbow? Well, it's just
beautiful. Everybody could fit along.
It's beautiful colors. They're
flamboyant. They're like a lot of colors.
But all those colors together,
like Yay.
Everyone's getting along with
all the colors. Flamboyant. No.
Can you say all know this bears
right? There has to be. There's, yeah,
because some of the guys still
like, yeah. Did you guys shit,
Shit. Fuck, fuck. Ah, fine.
Nothing wrong with that.
But the words is what kills
him. F word. I don't say it.
Don't say Donald Serone please,
please make a donation here.
It's one of those words
as growing up as kids,
it didn't really mean a gay person
like Louis Ck had a whole bit about it.
That didn't mean you didn't.
But we're supposed to evolve our folks
at call you a fancy. I've done that.
I don't mean it like that as me. You
don't mean this is a gay person, bitch.
I don't mean you're a female dog. It's
just, it's just, it's the same word.
Bitch is like level one. But faggot
is like the gold level. It's like,
listen, we're not playing around
and playing. You said it, you
cut. If I add the gas,
didn't hear like you fucking
cunt, Bro. That's, I went there,
I went to the, at def con five.
But if we're in London or in the no
man's Land Australia and they just say,
oh, you fucking cheeky. Cont
you know, they think it's cut.
It's the word they use.
Yeah.
So I guess because they use
it all. I mean, I don't know,
just words, the words. Yeah, words
are words, but it's, you know,
if they're ineffective, you know, and also
would they hurt so bad? Yeah. Do you can,
you can kill. I mean, dude, you,
especially if there's some reality to it.
That's the thing. Like I promise today
we're going to get some good ones.
There's going to be some,
yeah, but you can't read those.
I'm going to read them and I'm like,
how are you hard right next to him.
He was such a big, you're living your
life. Use this big character. Why?
Why paid God? I love you.
I love living a life.
I wish more people would get out
there and live life. Joe. Yeah, the,
I get so much shit for that.
Like I can't believe you're not training.
You're out living. And I said, man, look
at my life like I'm retired right now.
Why do I want to do all this cool
shit when I'm 50 and I can't,
I can do right now in my prime
will. Also, when people are young,
they do whatever they want to do.
I then,
it's like when you get old you're
supposed to become more serious. Sure.
I remember when you decided to try to be
more serious for a while and it fucked
you up. Fuck me up. It wasn't the way
you limited your expression. Yeah.
That's a good way to throw it in because
I think I love doing all this wild to
create living who you are is having fun.
Yeah.
It's like the like if I die here and
you're like cowboy, change of plans.
We're not doing the podcast,
we're going skydive and I'd be like,
you are you speaking to my heart?
I'm going to do a podcast from skydiving.
Skydiving.
So tell me about John.
Why did they make you wear rainbow shirt?
Why a rainbow?
30 seconds.
It'd be a very short podcast.
Well, the UFC has to do damage control
on savages, which is hilarious. Yes.
I have a bunch of people like you and Mike
Perry and you know, fill in the blank.
All these savages running around saying
crazy shit. And you go, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa,
Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, whoa, Whoa, whoa.
Do you ever go to a Derrick Lewis,
his Instagram page? I love it. I love it.
Where does he get the videos? No Man. He's
got all of them. All of them. What is it?
Uh, is it, uh, the
beast? MMA? What is his,
a plugin. Yeah. Beast. UFC.
Derrick Lewis. Shout out to Jerry.
Derrick Lewis is fighting volt con.
He's focused.
He's fighting that giant Russian dude.
Tell him, Derek, let's not do the same.
I know your bag was her phone or
her back was hurting. Last fight.
That was the craziest Fred
I've ever seen in my life.
Let's throw more than five
punches this fight. But he's
like, he was waiting. Yeah.
Alexander Volkov the beast.
UFC The beast. Got It. Yeah.
He's got the most hilarious
Instagram page and anytime does
anything fucked up that it's on video.
It's on his, on his eye. He's on all day.
That is so bad. You see the guy
shit eat shit. Swatch and dark.
It's just so crazy that he,
he puts all these in there.
Where do you, where do you hear
about accidents? All of them.
There's one that he has like real recently
within the last couple of weeks of
this guy standing on
the side of the highway.
What is the girl with the boobs and
click on that. What's happening here?
There's somehow or another the nipples
aren't showing. That's amazing.
Maybe they're a little higher.
Incredible control. She goes, Hey don,
those nipples are in the wrong place.
So nibbles or should be.
There should be some aerial hanging
out. Yeah, because you got no areola.
She's an alien.
That's barely a person.
Do you think aliens have beautiful
girls or are they beautiful alien?
I think they gave up on pussy.
This is what I think.
What does this guy get this guy for?
Stop it if you are,
if you think your life is bad,
these are Simon's brother.
One is gay and they just got one
ass. Oh my God. Are they really?
Oh God.
Did you hear it?
That you just said is that
really think your life is bad?
One is gay and one ass
kissing one of them.
That's the, that's not real. That's
the general part. Yeah. Kissing.
I don't even want to know if he has one
ass part is what clears into the Ras to
scroll down. If you could
see the accident. If you
go, there's a highway video.
So this is the gentlemen from hours
basis. No, that's sign it. That's funny.
I haven't seen that one. I haven't seen
the jumping from outer space one. Um,
but there's one where a guy's standing
on the side of the highway right next to
a black SUV and someone plows into the
SUV at full blast and someone else flies
out of the back of the SUV,
flies into the air and lands in their
feet and starts walking. Come on.
It's fucking crazy. He posts
so many. This is crazy. I mean,
how far was it? No. Did they pull it?
Where's he at with the rattlesnake?
What's the date of that?
What is the rattlesnake one happening?
Oh yeah. He probably got it pulled.
His shit gets pulled.
Does it get hold, I guess?
Yeah.
People find out about it,
but people sometimes outer space jump.
I haven't seen it. That ain't it. Whoa.
Crashes has to crash.
Someone does.
Yeah. I love it. I love
pushing the little, uh,
last button on the Instagram and
watching all the crazy videos like, yeah,
get on a tangent and go. There's so
many now. It's like so much fucked up.
There is this one novices in the same
one. He's got so many of these, man.
Oh Jesus. Whoa. What is this?
A high speed chase. Oh, Jesus.
I'm going to wait for it.
Oh, I'm wait, I'm sorry. What if
Frank's on his videos? That loop. Oh,
there it is. Right
here. Boom. Ba boom. Oh,
Jesus.
That one wasn't as good.
Yeah. The one where the guy
flies out naked and starts
walking on the highway was
amazing. Maybe that's it. Hold on. Go
back right there. What does that one,
it looks like a bear standing up. Go
back. How would that one be? It is a cat.
No, hold on. Go back to a record.
That's a cat. A Roomba. Oh, okay.
Magic being as smooth as this cat washes
the Roomba cubs. Drm touches them.
It's like
he's used to the room, but
that's all that is. Oh yeah.
That's what it is.
Bitchy turn.
She better get the buzzy for that
better. Right. Ready to fight. That's it.
Looks like to care of the fight or
the cat fight. Jesus Cowboy 33 30.
Was that me? Time flew by. God, we just
did three hours. Welcome mother fuckers.
That was awesome. Yeah. Hopefully they uh,
hopefully people don't get mad at
you for you. Use of the f word.
The equal use. Equal
shared. We shared that.
I use it only in referenced the time cop
smells things. My word, the word limiting.
Limiting expression in strange ways today.
Yeah.
Half of it is as much about people getting
mad at you and wanting to be able to
censor you or to get control of you or
to be angry at you or to shut you down or
get you fired to get you to put that
rainbow shirt on. It's like half of it.
Well,
we're going to do, what are
you going to do? So in a way,
two years and we're going to get more
stories when we're coming back. Yeah,
so this is Mike Perry fight is one
November 10 10th that's in Denver too,
right? DENVER, Colorado.
Some crazy rumors about you thinking
about moving back to Denver? No,
I'm just moving my family up there.
There's not really left for them in New
Mexico. I'm not there with Jackson's.
I'm buying a house in Denver. Move.
Oh, you are going to buy a house.
I moved away from the kid up there and
have him fly back to the ranch and train
BMF ranch.
I ain't going nowhere.
It's stuck and that's the cold leader
wants to hit me up by it. Other than that,
not would you rather live
in Denver and love it? Yeah,
I've had my roots not
been set. Right, right.
I had just got blindsided.
No, Denver's amazing.
It's a, it's one of the
best mixes of like country,
city,
beautiful scenery,
but it has every like Mama, grandma,
they're all there. You know,
the people are very cool. Yeah.
It's so, it's a very cool city.
One of my all time monsters
to go. I agree. He's one of
my favorite places to go.
Alright, shout outs. All the gay people
hope nobody was offended. Shout out to uh,
everybody else. Bisexuals,
trans people with big Dicks,
feel free to use that bathroom sleeve.
Those big alone.
Shout out to everybody out there. Just
trying to be good person to everybody. Uh,
distributing that plant medicine.
I said the earth ground. Yeah.
Shout out to Paul Stamets say test,
but cannot all if people
shout out to young Jamie. Hey,
how about that? All right,
well listen brother, I'm glad to do
this man to man Donald Cowboy Cerrone,
ladies and gentlemen.
We'll be back soon. Bye.
Okay.